[Music]
[Music]
homie look what I become
[Music]
okay so today's podcast is a special one
it's with the great Neil deGrasse Tyson
who has 22 honorary doctorates he has
received NASA's distinguished public
service medal the organization's highest
civilian honor written best-selling
books has had multiple shows has worked
under president's Administration done so
many different things the man's lived an
incredible life and he agreed to come
and be a guest on our podcast today
which we appreciate you for making the
time well I happen to be driving by I
love it it was great it was a long drive
you made in a rocket ship nonetheless so
22 doctors is there a story actually no
well this spring will be 22. okay in
this instant it's 21. got it but uh you
know an honorary doctorate you show up
and then they hand it to you and I've
and there's always this question
it's not real you know why do you even
why is it even in a resume and then I
was visiting the head of NASA a few
years back and I told him I was headed
off to an honorary degree ceremony later
that day and he said you're probably
discounting it in some way I say yeah a
little bit right and he said no here's
what it is
he said your actual PhD
the one you earned through many years of
graduate school
that's the promise
that you will one day do something great
but the honorary degree is the evidence
you have wow what an explanation yeah
that's a great story so but but so so
that changed my perspective sure degrees
but apart from that what I want is
sympathy from both of you that I sat
through 21 graduations we sympathize
with you yes okay our deepest sympathies
for you which one was the best one was
there one that stuck out they're on
stage and people they everybody's name
and all the parents are taking pictures
and I did that 21 times was there anyone
that stuck out was there a message you
heard where you said that that one I
still remember no there's no messages
but I remember uh at the University of
Pennsylvania okay uh that that took
place in their stadiums it was outdoors
and it felt festive because of that
rather than in just some smaller Hall
yeah yeah so 22 soon to be 20. 21 right
now yeah how many you do have I'm
working on my GED she will complete them
they already graduate high school with a
1.8 GPS out of reading first book I
finished cover to cover I was 21 years
old and then I read 2000 business books
so for me my obsession came very late
okay so it was yeah we we obsess
with precocious children on the
assumption that though they will become
amazing great adults whereas you just
happen to be catching someone in a phase
of their life where they read a lot or
learn a lot or learn fast yeah doesn't
mean you can't do exactly that later and
it doesn't mean it's any less valuable
to you or to society later that's a good
point don't you think that people should
learn more after they graduate school
than during school like throughout the
rest of their life okay so you're gonna
get me started let's get this thing hold
me back hold me back so
think about it just think about the
what's actually happening when
graduation day let's go back to high
school right you know there were people
if not yourself on the last day of
school
what sorry last day in the spring last
day you know before summer the people
say school's out for summer and the
School's Out forever great rock songs I
don't know if that's where you're going
with school's out for the summer people
cheer School's Out forever they cheer
even more and we have a a rock so what's
that Alice Cooper yeah yeah okay so so
and people you can picture this tossing
their notes in the air as they descend
done with learning okay and then I think
to myself oh my gosh yeah
we have failed
as Educators to instill a sense of
Eternal curiosity within you so that you
become a lifelong learner you will spend
many more years of your life not in
school than in and if you're glad you're
out of school then your knowledge of the
world your wisdom your insights have
ossified in that moment and that then
becomes
your Forever perspective on decisions
you make in life yet the world keeps
changing and so so the failure the
educational system is you think and you
believe and you feel that learning is a
chore rather than a delight
and that's got to change otherwise what
what kind of world are we making for us
you know there was a story about two
different uh uh athletes I think it was
Federer and tight tiger how they became
the greatest of all time in their space
where tiger was methodical with a
disciplinarian mom and dad and it was
kind of intentional at two years old
this guy's gonna learn how to golf and
Military all this stuff and then Federal
was kind of like he fell in love with
the game himself it's just kind of like
in organic yes and it was two different
one enjoyed it more than the other the
way where Federer actually enjoyed the
journey when tiger created a lot of
unnecessary pressures it's like being an
auto die deck which is like something
you want to do yourself yeah so I I
would also yes in addition to that
consider that what is the ceremony of
graduation called it's called what
graduation no no but the thing the event
is commencement oh commencement speech
correct yeah commencement commencement
speech all right so commence means to
begin
it doesn't mean to end the beginning of
your journey I would say the beginning
of of your journey
being a lifelong learner and that's what
I try to instill in people as adults if
I'm with you I want to celebrate
learning new stuff with you every moment
we're together Neil when when I think
about I'm sorry when I think about
you're not sorry you want to knock them
out of there we brought them in when we
realized there's more than an hour but
okay when when uh when I think about
teachers in my life that impacted my
life right like that you know Miss uh uh
Sinclair before you tell me about her I
will tell you about her and I've never
met you or her before today I think so
yes are you ready go for it
um you loved her class not because
she gave good exams or because the
homework was enlightening you loved your
class because she was passionate about
the subject she was teaching am I right
or wrong no question about it she was a
major in the Army so I joined the army
okay uh and you know yesterday I'm
having a conversation one of our guys at
my house
by the way she was 4 10. she was 4 10.
no joke she was 410 today were pen pals
huh she was health and guidance okay
yeah so till today I went back and
surprised her now we're friends every
time she dates somebody she introduced
them to me and I'm I'm playing a
different role in our life today than I
did before but it's more family very
very different kind of a relationship
none of the you know just a very good
relationship together but question
question for you is how much of a person
being good in a subject has to do with
interest that the individual has versus
the teacher that has a way of teaching
that you know gets interest gets
excitement like when I listen to you
talk I get excited because you're
excited about out a topic right how much
of it has to do I'm interested in math
how much has to do most mad teachers
suck
do you know what I'm saying I mean
because you know sometimes some people
say I hate math but there's a question
you're such a math guy that could any of
teacher inspired you to to learn more
about math yeah so so I have several
ways to approach that please so I
tweeted once that was needlessly
controversial I think people didn't
pause and think deeply enough about what
I posted because I I put way more
thought into a tweet than most people
put into their reaction to it and so
that creates a a sometimes ships are
sailing in the night my comment was
students who get straight A's
do so not because of good teachers but
in spite of Bad Teachers
and
what that means is
if you get straight A's that meant you
got straight A's even when you had bad
teachers
that's what Straight A's means so the
quality of the teacher was irrelevant to
your performance
so you're an independent learner yeah at
that point then there are people who get
bad grades everywhere
so good teachers didn't make any
difference to them so they're bad
students but for most people a good
teacher enables them to do better and a
bad teacher they don't do as well that's
for most people and so so all I'm saying
is
we need good teachers and Bad Teachers
there should be a way to filter them out
fire them no really though because the
10 years are you with the 10 year system
we all know who the bad teachers are
sure everybody why do we keep them
though because we need a way to make
that measurement and it's hard it's
difficult without worrying about some
kind of bias I would say two years later
students assess who their worst teacher
was that way their grade is not
dependent yeah and they're out and they
don't you know they're not they got
nothing invested anymore in it and then
let that sit on their record that
that'll filter teachers immediately I
think great teachers are I think great
teachers are underpaid uh uh I think
average teachers are getting paid what
they're getting paid and I think bad
teachers need to be filtered out and get
fired unfortunately the system doesn't
allow for it right now right right so
that has to be that would need to be
modified first of all but second getting
back to your point yeah yes I think
they're people who are who are
self-driven and if they do what they
love they will probably be better at
that than anything else that they might
be told to do can I give you a
perspective and you challenge me I love
okay no I don't if it's if it's
objectively verifiable I won't challenge
you so you so you know like I want to
ask that I had a girl in my office uh uh
you know with uh one of our guys his
wife is sitting there and she's like
look I'm not a big fan of rich people
I'm like okay tell me why and we're
having this guy I said did you like math
in school she says no I can't stand math
so I started asking Democrats and
Republicans both questions are you a
math person are you a science person are
you an uh PE are you more what are you
and one of the things I notice is a lot
of guys on the right were math people a
lot of the guys on the left were more
science more journalism more creative
more art is where they were at so do you
think a part of like what you're saying
is there are those are going to get good
grades no matter who the teacher is
dardos are going to get bad grades no
matter who the teachers and then there
are those in the middle like an
independent that's open to being in you
know persuaded to get better in math or
science if the teacher is a good teacher
right so what's the question the
question is does somebody are there
those that no matter if you give them a
great teacher or a bad teacher they're
going to get bad grades and no matter if
you give them a good teacher about
they're going to get great grades okay I
have another response today please and
another controversial tweet which really
shouldn't have been all right the Tweet
was
how often do we hear teachers say
the students just don't want to learn
when that teacher should really be
saying I suck at my job
as an educator it is my duty to figure
out what key works in your ability to
learn and if I don't am I going to run
around and blame you or gonna say to
myself I was too lazy to put in the
extra effort to figure it out so I
operate on the principle that if I'm not
succeeding in the first few moments of
my encounter with you it's my duty and
obligation as an educator to figure out
what you care about so that I can teach
you things in a way that matters to you
and that you can continue in life
continuing powerful you can continue in
life with a level of curiosity that by
the way as children we're all curious
as adults it's been beaten out of us or
it's a flame has has dimmed and so what
I want to do is fan those Embers
reignite them in your adulthood
so that you can have this childhood
curiosity about things you don't know
that we all once had how much of of that
analogy or is essentially the scientific
method that you're applying to to
teachers meaning like hey you're going
through the science uh project all right
cool didn't work let's keep going again
let's keep trying again I have a
hypothesis let's figure it out and but
it sounds very similar it's never unlike
what many people think it's never
really about the answer
because at some point you want to learn
to love the questions themselves because
the questions are the seeds of curiosity
questions are I wonder and I don't know
so parents who have kids I don't know if
you guys have kids if you have kids
because Mommy Daddy what's this what's
that or Mommy Mommy what's this what's
that right whatever is the modern
blended family and so
the parent then gets the answer or
doesn't have the answer they find it
okay
maybe your reply should be
I don't know let's figure it out
and it's the figuring out of the answer
that's
within what a scientist does who said
the staying with problems longer is that
an Einstein quote somebody said genius
is staying with the problems longer uh
uh where you're not giving up right
before it gets hard somebody sustained
with problems yeah I don't know who that
might have been but that I'm all with it
I'm all in on that so so Neil so this is
your world you know what else genius is
just seeing what everyone else has seen
but thinking what no one else has
thought
seen what everyone has seen but thinking
what nobody else has thought that's
correct and so those thought pathways
are empowered by your life experience
how many different ways have you seen
problems or moments or incidences or
people places things so that now we all
see the same thing but I will make a
connection that maybe you don't because
I have the capacity to make these
connections within my mind and so that's
very important so I I'm a big uh
promoter of just a person's total life
experience for you to draw upon for
every next thought you might have
now is there genius also for Bible
that's a quote about Einstein I'm not
that's uh it's not that I'm so smart
it's just that I stay with problems
longer that's a powerful quote but is
genius also uh by the way he really was
smart no he really was but by the way a
lot of people call you the modern day
Einstein no no no no you you I'm saying
maybe not yourself but other people call
you no no uh and and the the one thing
that I want to know if it's if it's
mandatory as well is it mandatory for
somebody to be genius to be recognized
as a sexiest astrophysicist Alive by
People magazine and have the voice that
you have and you got like this Coast
103.5 hey so caller who who would you
like to dedicate the song too
you know what I'm here at the love album
[Laughter]
it's a very white type of a voice you go
okay I didn't what I really wanted when
Jamesville Jones no longer was the voice
for CNN I wanted to I wanted to do that
this is CNN you have it that was I
totally wanted to jump in there but to
be to be real just to be very clear on
this ultimately what you are doing not
not an opinion I think it's Universal
fact you are making science sexy I said
it but that's kind of what you're doing
yeah let me I would think of it a little
differently I I would say let me get
back to the point about that that
designation from People magazine uh just
to be clear was 50 pounds ago
rob you know what that means that was up
back in 2000 and and just to be clear
that that issue because every year
People magazine has its sexiest man
alive issue I was in a category so
sexiest astrophysicist I don't know how
competitive that kind of wow really
beat out Stephen Hawking I don't know
plastic go no that's what I'm saying
sexiest astrophysics more competitive
categories yeah sexiest action star
sexiest news anchor yeah did some hunky
news anchors out there
sexiest meteorologist and sexiest uh
model yeah and then sexiest
astrophysicist so the person on the
cover yeah which is transcends category
was Brad Pitt which makes sense it
doesn't make sense sexiest man alive 2
000. let's go back to the educational
thing let's go back to the school system
so with what we have today with what we
have going on annotated with a current
educational system one do you think it
produces the best product too if you had
influence over changing two three four
five things with our current educational
I'm talking purely public not private
because private is different in the
public side what would you change about
our current educational system a lot and
one day I'm going to write a book on
that because I have a lot of ideas
they're still in the oven so that
literally means they're Half Baked at
this moment I'm still working on what
ideas I can put forth
that are fully supported by evidence by
rational thinking a lot of people just
say what they think is right and then
it's subject to a lot of comments or
criticisms and and I I want to make sure
all the t's across one that you you're
pretty confident about give us one that
you would say if I were to change one
thing about our educational system this
is the one that I can confidently speak
on broadly and the way I would change
the science is another thing but let me
say broadly
I would say
that I would de-emphasize the
value the educational system places on
what grades you got yeah
and figure out ways to assess or rather
to promote or to nurture
your
enthusiasm for learning
and because of this what happened you
know what happens there are people who
get high grades these are the people who
pay attention in class and all their
homeworks are handed in on time and they
might become valedictorian and
however if you look at the biggest
shakers and movers in society in
practically any field
none of them were valedictorians the
most if you've read a lot of business so
you know CEOs were never the top of
their class or entrepreneurs whenever
the top of their class they were too
distracted by other thoughts and ideas
and and look at Richard Branson who his
Headmaster said you'll either be in
prison or be a millionaire that's right
he ended up a billionaire that's right
because he was not following these
educational rules about what would
enable a teacher to judge that you will
go far and my grades in school were
pretty average
because they were average no teacher at
any time in my life K through 12 16 and
20. okay
would have ever said see that guy Tyson
watch him he'll go far
none of them even though I was all into
the universe no one said that no one
would have said that had you asked had
you walked into the classroom and I'm in
the class and that's the teacher who's
going to go far in this class I would
have never shown up on their beloved Any
teacher yet it's not like I was a late
bloomer I've known I was interested in
the universe since I was nine and at age
11 you asked me what I want to be when I
grow up that annoying question adults
always asking I said I want to be an
astrophysicist and I was in the
astronomy club and I walked dogs and
used that money walked other people's
dogs use that money to buy my first
telescope at age my first time at age 14
and I had cameras I had a dark room who
knows what a dark room is anymore but
that's why I produced all my photography
all of this was going on and it doesn't
show up on a grade in my school and so
the teacher doesn't see that they don't
know it they don't even care they just
care what grade you've got and so here I
am growing myself and had this whole
library of books my parents would buy
remaindered books they cost 50 cents
they just they didn't know any science
but if they saw a science book or a math
book they bought it for I had the
biggest library of any middle schooler
there ever was okay so all of this is
going on and in high school I went on an
expedition to to to Scotland to view the
stone monuments that are similar to
Stonehenge but many are not charted and
I was on expedition to chart them I was
the localist I was the astronomer
brought in with archaeologists and
anthropologists all this is happening
I spent a summer in an astronomy Camp
living nocturnally in the desert in the
Mojave Desert while I was in high school
none of that shows up as a grade and
what I'm all I'm saying is
a person is so much more than the
numerics of their GPA
that if you only focus on a GPA you will
lose people
there'll be people who will go
unrecognized unsupported
unidentified in the school system how do
we grade the other part though how do we
grade that's that's the challenge yeah I
don't know how you would now try to
encode ambition or drive these are more
passion especially these are a little
more abstract and maybe the school
rather than judging you whether you have
passion yeah they should find ways to
instill passion within you and then
you're graded by how much more passion
you had after the class than you did
before rather than how much you walked
in there with well let me ask you this
so here's the other question so for me
having ran a sales organization for 20
some years I'll see somebody come in and
I used to say man that guy's a great
talker he's going to do great in sales
one month later he quits and he goes to
the next and the next and you'll see
another guy like well it just means you
suck at evaluating but but I did you're
right but but you're right no I'm just
no no but you but but neither the point
he's trying to clown you but he's like
no you're right I agree with you as as a
newer sales leader I did then when I
learned we built a 40 000 Insurance
Agency company Nationwide and I'm the
founder of it so I learned how to lock
onto the right people here's a question
for you so what should be the key
indicator maybe two or three indicators
to say this 16 year old kid this 14 year
old kid this 17 year old kid could one
day do something very big in their lives
or is it too early to tell you it could
surely be too early to tell which is why
you always want to
present opportunities to people
throughout their lives to see if they'll
jump on them modify them make them fit
their lives all I will say is when
assessing the promise and performance
of a student
you need to look at more than their GPA
I don't mind standardized exams I don't
mind you want to give somebody an IQ
test I don't have a problem with any
test but the moment you administer a
test
and then use that against the person
because they didn't score high enough on
this test above some threshold that you
have cut off and only then do you give
them opportunities this is using
Educational Systems and tools against
the progress of students rather than for
them when I was in sixth grade there was
still contained in an elementary school
I was not in what they call the smartest
class because they they they were
identified by the system and and they
took French
they took a foreign language and I said
well why can't I take a form well you're
not you're you you don't belong in that
class okay you got to go in the second
class and they would given opportunities
that I really wanted to have
and I was denied it because some
educational construct declared that I
was Unworthy of it
and so uh that I've been thinking about
that ever since because I was already
ambitious as a kid
I I I I don't this isn't a pushback but
it's like Pat was a 1.8 GPA student
but and your your subject was math right
like if you could have just dedicated
all your time to math I would do math
with you made me do it or not I don't
know what kind of grades you got
sometimes somebody tells me you did okay
but I got a mixture of A's B's and C's
which average to B I guess my point is
like but it all worked out okay meaning
like you're the most famous
astrophysicist in the world it worked
out that was horrible at everything else
he's amazing at business math it worked
out I was always like an actor thespian
here I am so it worked out no no no no
no no it's not just it worked out no
somewhere in there you are standing up
after you've been knocked down multiple
times that's not just it worked out
that's where your drive is your grit
your ambition Your Capacity to recover
from any forces operating against your
your all of this so it's not just it
worked out I'm where I am not because of
my educational past but in spite of it
God is my point so you're saying the
school system should have done it should
do a better job identifying what you're
super super passionate about or let you
double down on that versus useless no no
that's being more specific than I'm
prepared to land at this moment yeah but
what a school should say is
don't Reserve all your highest Praises
for the people who get the highest
grades do some other searching in the
total life of the person suppose there's
someone who who is who in in middle
school or high school is taking care of
the younger kid babysitting walking dogs
doing this uh shopping do it and figured
out a way to make that efficient and
I've created a budget for the family
because they couldn't figure that look
what that is oh my gosh the person is
figuring out life and no one was there
to train them that's ambition that's
some of it is the the necess the what do
you call it the um Necessities the
mother of invention or or in order to
survive you got to be get clever okay
but these are tests of us throughout our
lives if you're a deadbeat sitting at
home watching TV and and you don't have
good grades I got nothing for you at
that point
but take a look at the total package
because in life the total package is
what's going to matter okay so let me
let me ask you a question I had a
teacher I teach a couple this is going
to show up in this education book I have
teacher comment I still have my report
cards uh Neil is
um should
um
less social involvement and more
academic diligence is in order
what they're saying is my social energy
my social energy was a negative in that
classroom by the way I wasn't purposely
disruptive it was more a gurgling of
energy just you know okay that was a
negative
and meaning you would socialize with our
students you were talkative you were
energetic I passed notes and things yeah
that was bad rather than saying there
could be some value to this later on he
might become a communicator because he's
communicating with all these people at
all these different times no one is
thinking that right all they can see is
the grade in their class that's why none
of the teachers would have said look at
him he'll go far Neil in your class by
the way I asked this question about two
months ago and it was incredible hearing
the answer what does the valedictorian
of your high school do for work today
did they meet and exceed the expectation
if I tell you 95 the responses was no
yeah of course it was oh no no no but
but going back by the way that's not
true for my valedictorian but who was
yours what did he do what did he or she
do he was co-founded regeneron
um
the biomed company yeah he was my
valedictorian my Year from the Bronx
High School that's insane what year who
he is what number did you finish the
Bronx High School of Science
um there were about 700 graduates I they
don't number it below 10 but I was
probably 300 350th got it who else was
very successful in your school outside
of him
uh he and I have our names on the school
wall
um I have to think about okay so then
that means you we don't so did you did
you see any signs of genius or something
different about him where you said this
guy could do something in his life or no
at the time yeah um he was very
ambitious I mean he did science fair
projects which again are extra
curricular additional on top on top of
the grade for that thing and uh here's
something interesting he did because he
competed I think if I remember correctly
competed in the famous Westinghouse
science challenge search and did very
well in that when he became regeneron
that
that science Talent shirt has changed
quote ownerships over the years and now
there's the regeneron prize out of the
monies that they have invested in it
yeah so so uh that I so I'm just saying
if you're just looking at grades that's
the person who is trying to impress you
here's here's the measure I got it for
you ready
uh
if you got a 97 on your exam
instead of a hundred
are you gonna complain to your teacher
are you going to complain if it's like
hand graded and are you gonna complain
we don't okay it's 97's just as good as
100 I don't care if you're going to
complain that means you're after the
grade more than you're after learning
and at some level valedictorians are
after the grades
and that
ask anyone who's 30 and older in this
world when was the last time someone
wanted to know your GPA they won't even
be able to remember
it never comes up at work it's are you
honest are you moral are you a hard
worker do you solve problems whole sets
of qualifications that are not encoded
in your GPA
or SAT score or AC system or anything
like that same difference so how
important are extracurricular activities
meaning like you might have gotten been
a b student but you're captain of the
debate team or you're on the football
team or the wrestling team captain of my
wrestling oh were you really yeah okay
so I'm defeated by the way in high
school but but that's very high news
right it's not in Iowa okay just to be
clear there are places where people were
wrestling as a religion and I was
undefeated in a place where wrestling is
not a religion so so so going back so I
had these extra things that was my rest
of my life I did fun thing I did things
that that not only
were activities there were activities
that further grew my knowledge and
awareness of fields so so I I
interviewed a guy named Billy Bean I
bought him three times and he if you've
seen a movie Moneyball with your friend
Brad Pitt who
yeah yeah me and Brad hey sexiest man
alive in 2000. you guys are in the same
Spectrum we just share yeah magazine so
I brought him on board and I said hey
Billy this guy was supposed to be the
greatest Prospect in baseball the year
he came out literally that's a story he
comes out they're like number one pick
this guy's gonna crush it he's gonna be
it biggest flop and he's telling his own
story and I said so what are the
indicators of baseball because they were
able to figure out what stat was the
most important which was on base
percentage but then he said by the way I
think baseball's become over
statisticified and that's another
conversation yeah it's probably because
of him by the way well yeah maybe it was
had some tap Roots there but baseball
you know has always been about
statistics
and they're trying to move against it by
preventing the shift in the Outfield or
the info what he's trying to say maybe
it's making a little bit boring because
you know the pictures are pitching out
pitching two winnings and the next guy
that's a very weird amount of Tampa Bay
anyways I don't want to go to baseball
but I want to stay on this with the hood
if you wanted to yeah I'm sure you could
handle it I got totaled okay but go on
maybe we could ask this question I think
you could get if you get hit by the
pitch on Ball Four you should go to
second base
so not just the walk because it was
intentional but sacrifice that the
picture take anyway no no I'm saying you
would go to first base on Ball Four you
would go to first base if you were hit
by a pitch should like that idea if
you're hit by a pitch on Ball Four you
should go to second I actually like that
idea they have a lot of thoughts I
actually like that idea a lot yeah yeah
so what he said is he said four things
character like upbringing actual body
attitude discipline and then it was a
whole different thing that he had there
so and then that's how they judge
whether they should invest in this guy
or not recruit him or not you know I
asked you earlier indicators would you
be able to give a couple indicators to
say here could be some indicators of
like hey this kid's extremely curious
that's one of seven indicators of
success yes what are some things you
would say okay so what I would say uh to
get mathematical on you uh why don't we
think of each of these features of a
person as dimensions of a hypercube
okay okay oh you're pulling out your
notes here yeah both gonna write down
what a hypercue okay so all right so
like we can start what's the what is the
measure of a line well just its length
and there's no other metric sure most
measures we have of people are just this
one-dimensional thing are you higher on
that or are you lower on that okay any
exam is a one-dimensional measure of
people who take the exam let's add
another coordinate so that's an x-axis
let's add a y-axis and now the measure
of two lines
is a square
there's not there's no such thing as the
length of two perpendicular lines but
what the two perpendicular lines do is
is is Trace out an area which would be
the area of a square so now we can say
let's say there are two things about you
uh how good are your grades and how
sociable are you those are otherwise not
correlated so now I can calculate an
area
for you all right well maybe some other
things matter but maybe some other
things how about ambition that would be
a third coordinate now I'm not measuring
your length or your area I'm measuring
your volume
and now let's add a fourth coordinate so
it's what we have uh um what do we have
we had linear the linear your grades
your your social skills your ambition
and how about here's one which wouldn't
necessarily be the other three Your
Capacity to recover from failure
oh okay so now I have four dimensions
this could go higher but I have four
dimensions what's the quote hyper volume
of the four dimensions you multiply all
four of those measures
and then you have a volume and I would
say that the success of somebody is not
where they are on any one-dimensional
scale they're where they are in this
hyper volume
and they could be less on one and more
on another but all that volume is a
dynamic place
and what you'd want to do is maximize
that volume before you hire somebody
it'll be a hyper volume
I love that by the way you can choose
choose your mate the same way are they
good looking does it matter okay but if
you only choose them only because
they're good looking and then one day
they get older and less good looking
does that mean you're going to love them
less yes it will mean that if that's the
only reason why you got together which
happens many times what happens many
times okay do you want them also for
their money it sounds shallow but that's
not any more shallow than liking someone
for their sure Beauty sure it's just
another thing so might they one day lose
their money that's possible unless it's
deep family money but okay but and how
about are they have a sense of humor
um are they ambitious there's a volume
and then you can put everybody and scale
it from zero to ten on each of those
right multiply it out you have a volume
now you can take all your your mates
that the potential mates scale them this
way and what happens is because you're
multiplying this out
they end up spreading hugely on a scale
and it becomes obvious who the best one
is at that point obvious we did this
when we were looking for a home
we was like okay was it affordable is it
nearby work uh do I is it is it is it or
is all the appliances or are the
appliances new do you like the
neighborhood these are coordinates judge
it from zero to ten by the way if any
coordinate is zero
everything drops out because you're
multiplying all right so if it's zero on
any of these coordinate walk keep moving
there's nothing there okay no matter how
good anything else looks to you all
right if then give it a one fine all
right so there we are and then you can
throw in a category called intangibles
I just it just feels right to me that's
allowed yeah I'm writing it down this is
allowed so let that be an extra
coordinate there then okay multiply it
out as you go to each one that's how we
chose uh the home to buy my wife and I
and by the way it's also how I decided
that
my wife was like the right person for me
I looked at all the coordinates of what
I valued in a mate yeah and uh we've
been married 34 years can I ask you
specifically about your wife how did you
judge her are you saying obviously first
was like okay Beauty but like what are
these I I'm literally taking notes I
said no no you shouldn't go ahead don't
use me I want to know from your category
though my category am I attracted to her
yes you know if you can add things like
sex and you know this sort of thing or
are they fun to be with you can add all
of this yes
for me I value uh is she smart and
um and clever I'd like that so hot and
smart done what else what
I met her in graduate school she was
getting a PhD in mathematical physics
what about caring and motherly yeah so I
would didn't care at all about
motherliness but uh is the person kind
that the kind is she kind uh or
compassionate and so once you do this
there was no one else that came close on
the scale of anyone else I dated even
historically dated you know because you
might regret oh I should have Coulda did
right but I didn't no so looking back so
for me it was a mathematical exercise 35
years later 34 years 34 years sorry you
know I try to give you the Plus One Like
Pat try to give you the one plus one you
dated from when I proposed to her and
when she said yes because then that's
when the decision mattered and that was
probably 36 years you're you're uh
hypothesis 34 years ago versus you know
the actuality what Still Remains the
concept wait you know what you know what
it announced what Remains the constant I
can see other
people other women I see them and I say
yeah I'm still glad about my decision
hell yeah 35 years ago it's awesome
right I'm still glad nothing's worse
than buyers remorse but buyers remorse
exactly got it yeah how are you feeling
you would ask a question like that well
I think it's so like I think where we
started was yeah like what you know all
these qualifications of a good student
yeah but even it's applying to buying a
home picking a mate anything there's all
these qualities any decision you need to
make that's multi-variable multivariate
and you have to make sure that each
coordinate is completely independent of
the other coordinate and what I mean by
that is
um if you're trying to choose a choose
your mate you you can't have as two
separate categories uh uh you know she
looks hot with clothing on and with
clothing off those are not two separate
categories ah [ __ ] it's okay
it's a general hot yeah all right you
don't yeah you don't want to overlap
that because then there's
cross-contamination of the coordinates
and you don't you don't want that Pat I
don't want to turn this into a sauce
cast but I'm very confident that you did
this exact same thing with Jen with what
you must have like Jen was ambitious she
was beautiful she was a model she was a
worker the book I went through 101
questions to ask before you get engaged
second date that's what I did that gave
me a uh we went through six hours later
I'm like okay I know but and I went
through that website with four other
people three other people you
interviewed her well on the second day
that we went to borders and I bought the
book yeah we had known each other for
five years okay because it sounds like
an interview I don't disagree I think it
is and I answered mine as well and one
of the ones is if you say you have no
baggage you bring to the table run
because that person's lying to you
everybody's got something they bring to
I thought it was a very good exercise
that book right there by the way nine
years after I read the book I
interviewed the guy five seven years
that I interviewed the guy just because
I was curious with the questions let's
let's transition to another topic
speaking of the honesty part uh in the
film The Big Short uh one of my favorite
lines ever
was uh who's the guy who was this
slightly autistic guy Christian Michael
Berry reference him all the time here
his character
um he was describing the response of
someone on a dating app to what he
posted
okay and the person said I yes I want to
date you and but what did he put in the
dating app he said well I have a glass
eye and I'm a little I'm not entirely
socialized and I do that and I'm you
know but I'm caring and I but I'm I'm
you know there's all these like negative
things about them and the person wrote
in and said you're exactly who I'm
looking for and he said why I said
because you're honest
damn powerful whoa powerful by the way
you know he would be a very you know one
of the reasons why he doesn't do a lot
of interviews he doesn't do a lot of
interviews that would be a very
interesting conversation for the two of
you guys to have I think that would be a
fascinating conversation with Michael
Berry but let's transition to a couple
other topics there's a few topics I want
I want to go through I assume you had
like other stuff I have nothing topics
here so I will go fast one is open AI
one is Tick Tock one is China One is if
we got time astrology one is
billionaires one and anyway so let me
just pick one of them for us to get into
here right now so first ones uh uh your
opinion okay
um
uh uh and I'm curious to know what
you're going to say to this your answer
may be very different than what I expect
it to be so what is tougher what is
tougher to do and what is more worthier
to do in your opinion okay
um
I'm in high school I get out of high
school I'm ambitious okay
is it tougher to be
a person who
is at the level of intelligence to get
22 honorary doctorates you know these
Awards etc etc knowing all of these
different topics being well read Etc so
from zero to that is it tougher to be a
billionaire is it tougher to become the
best athlete in the world like a Tom
Brady is it tougher to make it to the
highest level as an actor where you're
like a you know Daniel Day-Lewis or at
that level type of a person what's
tougher or are all of them independent
to the individual
so it's that's a mathematically solvable
problem you ask how many people are at
that level and how many people are
trying to be at that level divide the
two numbers interesting and there you
have it yeah so it is tougher to be an
MBA star than it is to be a medical
professional a medical doctor it's
tougher statistics it's just statistics
right you can just do pure statistics
and but that alone should not stop you
because what you'd then be saying to
yourself is
I have these two roots and I'm more
likely to succeed here than there so I'm
not gonna go where my true love is
because I will probably not succeed well
that you've already kind of surrendered
didn't you and I would say that
you know I used I used to wrestle you
know you don't choose wrestling because
it's easy you choose wrestling because
it's hard
Kennedy said that about our space
program we choose to go to the Moon not
because it's easy but because it's hard
I can tell you this by trying most hard
things
even if you have to take an exit ramp
for having tried the hard thing you are
better off than having done something
easy
and anytime I ask I'm asking her advice
in school what classes should I take
what should I do I say take the hardest
possible classes you can
but then what about my GPA hey here it
comes again what about my GPA well okay
you can take an easy class and get a
high GPA that everyone will praise you
for for three months after graduation
but then because you took easy classes
everyone else
took the same easy class that's the
definition of easy isn't it and so you
will not distinguish yourself among
others who have been in school
so I've had people say I should know
this I had a 4.0 GPA no you should know
it because you studied it not because
you had a GPA that had anything to do
with it okay you should know because you
cared about it and you knew enough to
absorb it and remember it but apparently
you didn't because you only did it for
the exam so you're still peddling your
GPA about this so all I would say is
you're
uh oh it was that handsome guy right
there is that you as a wrestler what's
that all about yeah in high school
that's called College dude
I said that the sexiest astrophysics
live with clearly 50 pounds ago what
how much did you weigh then what did you
do in that instant 191 pounds oh you
were and you're six two six two six two
yeah you were yeah you were a monster
right there those biceps yeah I just
came off the mat and they said and the
guy was on the was like laying down on
the man took it so it's up at that angle
do you talk about this often because
I've never heard you address this that's
a chapter long gone I'm when I was when
I was wrestling when I was I also danced
when I was doing those things I no one
was publishing my books what kind of
dancing were you doing I was a
performing member of three different
dance companies
um but the college troops not the
Bolshoi by the way I think he needs to
know as much as you kind of were joking
at one point he considered being an
exotic dancer I think I've read it well
because I was in graduate school and
there wasn't you're not paid very much
as a teaching assistant and I thought
you were like you read up on it or not
no no no and so uh with my fellow
dancers from the dance
group I was
um I was in desperate need of money and
I had any money and he said hey we in
the evenings we dance at this uh male
dancer review and women put money in
your in your in your in your jock strap
and I so I said he said why don't you
come down take a look so I went down
this would be a way to make money back
then I was physically fit and I could do
a full split and I was I was graceful
and strong strong and Nimble so I I
totally could have rocked whatever and
was necessary for that I'm thinking so I
go there
and they come
they come out with asbestos line jock
straps
that had been infused with lighter fluid
and ignited
and they came out dancing to Jerry Lee
Lewis's Great Balls of Fire
in that instant I said hmm I think I'll
be a math tutor and I'm I'm deeply
embarrassed and disappointed with myself
that math tutor was not the first thing
that came to my head that I kept the
options though considered
on fire for me wow
mind-blowing it took me nuts on fire for
me to be to be slapped back into reality
so I tutored math in physics I thought
you were going to blow my mind with some
astrophysicists asked me about
astrophysics yet okay by the way what
was your your stage name at the time
no I I didn't have it I feel like I
would have had a great stage name for
you well what what the black hole oh
yeah no yeah no no no no no
right there with a better name right
yeah Dark Matter
[Laughter]
Pat this is should be a great segue for
you to talk about it I'm not doing it
because Dark Matter the James Earl Jones
please help us yeah so so the
point we were making here about uh
to do you do it because it's hard
you're a sports guy
I saw a guy making an argument why the
goat of goats isn't Brady it's messy and
the way the guy broke it down is there's
seven billion people fighting to be
eight billion people fighting to be the
best soccer player and it's a World
Sport and football's only 330 million
years pure numbers yeah they kind of
took the angle you were taking yeah
definitely do you know how many
billionaires there's in America you know
the number at this moment
um let me guess don't don't pull it up I
want to see what happens I'd like to
guess too but let me guess
don't pull it up I want to see what
you're going to say as well I'm going to
say
somewhere between
one and two hundred one at 200 what are
you going to say I don't know I'm just
thinking if I do get this right somehow
I'm going to beat no grass Tyson on a
smart
I'm going with I'm going with I'm going
with
195. 195.
so you guys think out of 330 million
people there's only 195 billionaires
yeah yeah 200 billionaires the number is
uh in the United States in the US I'm
not saying the world because I came into
that number because I've met like six of
them right and so nice little humble
bracket so many given my given that and
I'm in New York City where a lot of
billionaires are yeah I'm just
extrapolating up and I'm thinking there
might be some states where no
billionaires live you know so click on
it let's see how many it says the number
I think is 740 or 900. what 740 there
you go in the united states in the
United States is 740. oh we were they
live in 42 out of the 50 states so okay
very wrong 740 yeah but that number is
he is way higher than even just recently
right well no a lot of them lost a lot
of money this year so that's an updated
number because a lot of people lost
their status 2022 and 2020 yeah 2022 was
not a good year for billionaires
a thousand billionaires do you think
that's a big deal though do you for you
to say 100 to 200 100 do you think you
said that because you think it's hard to
do or do you think you said that because
why'd you say 100 to 200 I'm curious no
I extrapolated from the six that I know
there was no deep thought involved yes
based on those numbers yeah yeah and I
know seven billionaires so it's just
still not funny well he's a Miami he
parties with most of them anyway so a
lot of them are here okay but no no but
but you say
I let me just push back on you a little
just
um emotionally push back please
if in life your goal is to be a
billionaire what kind of life is that I
think your goal in life should be
successful at some thing and if that
happens to bring a lot of money then
that's great because then you'd be
happier and I think life happiness
should play an important role and I
don't know how I got to be a billionaire
otherwise I'm not going to be happy and
then what will what will that force you
to do
what kind of decisions will you end up
making to achieve that goal relative to
just trying to be the best at something
that you can now maybe it's you want to
be the best at making money
okay good luck okay but it reminds me of
actors okay if people say I want to be a
famous actor really you don't want to be
a really good actor you don't want to be
a great actor you just want to be a
famous actor why don't you be the best
actor you can be and let the fame follow
that
then you'll get the fame organically
with you having been ambitious in your
trade yeah the reason why I asked the
questions I got four kids and we're
having a conversation yesterday about
football how old are they uh 10 9 6 18
months 10 9 6 18 months yes he do I
would have 20 more if I could but you
know we're shutting it down so anyways
we're having this conversation about the
nine-year-old yesterday did I hear
vasectomy there is that we're shutting
it down nothing yeah he's getting one
yeah so his beautiful wife is shutting
it yeah so so the whole idea is if we're
going the route of uh uh if we're going
the route of you know what these kids
want to do in the conversation yesterday
was the youngest son nine-year-old wants
to play football my sister's like well
you know you sure you want to put them
in football with the stats and all this
other stuff we sat down and went out of
conversation with the guy so listen with
the nine-year-old we showed him videos I
know read Antonio Brown here's what he
said here's what this person said here's
a clip watch this clip watch that club
watch this clip the kid still wants to
play football there it is so no matter
how much you push him away you're not
going to be able to force the kid to do
what you want him to do you could but
you may create resentment you don't push
them away you just expose them to
information exactly and of course when
you're nine especially your brain is not
fully rationalized yet so I would
revisit it every couple of years with
your child
but your kid could be the most famous
football player there ever was and you
don't want to be the one who
who interfered with that plus football
is slowly getting safer relative to
decades ago take a look at the the hits
that Terry Bradshaw took
uh he looks like why is he still alive
all right and and their laws were put in
a place since then so I'm just saying as
a parent I think your goal should be not
to require they study or interested in
one thing or another but that they're
exposed to the the joys and the
sufferings of whatever it is they might
choose to do and then let them make
their own decision that would ensure
that it's a more organically arrived
down
I agree no we're on the same page with
that right there I thought you were
going to have an argument on why you
believe you know one is tougher to do
than the other but you took the
statistical route which makes sense I
mean you can really figure it figure
that out based on numbers open AI okay
open AI is a conversation I don't know
how much you're following chat gbt or
not no in six weeks these guys have gone
from zero in valuation to now being a 29
Billion Auto Company give or take okay
in six weeks and so in two years it took
Facebook two years to get to a million
users it took Instagram two years ago to
a million users it took Pinterest five
months to get to a million users it took
Angry Birds 34 days to get to a million
users it took chanji BT five days to get
two million users every other hour when
you're on chat gbt the website's shut
down because of the amount of activity
so you haven't used the app yet right
you haven't I know about it the website
yeah so what are your thoughts about the
direction we're going with AI and and
you know things like Chad gbt and what
else you see this thing going to I know
you made predictions on the Rogan show
where you said you know here's some of
the predictions I heard you know cancer
you know this well that stuff designed
to be shown that I would be wrong in 30
years they were not here's my crystal
ball it's all going to happen right it's
I in my chapter of the book I spent
Pages upon Pages showing how people's
predictions at the beginning of a
30-year period had no meaning at the end
of a 30-year period going from 1870 to
2020. and so I said so that you don't
think I'm just being mean to other
futurists I will join this exercise so
that in 30 years you can tell me how
wrong I am that was how where that came
out but I would say that that
um we can be impressed with what AI is
doing and we should be and so I don't I
don't have a problem with that but were
you worried what what's your what point
are you making about this no no because
there's the debate right now I'm very
neutral on this I love advancement I
love Innovation I'm excited about it but
this morning I'm having my CEO call with
our c-suites and I'm talking to our CTO
who is a guy that's done very well for
himself he's sold companies he's been
part of companies being acquired by IBM
for 700 million dollars he's on very
well so I said so what do you think
about this whole concept of Chad gbt
because the other day I don't know if
you can go to it see if it's working the
website's working right I know we're not
if okay switch over the connection is
secure not proceeding okay it's down
right now it's it's often down but
yesterday not yesterday Saturday we're
here shooting a video
and I said
write a 1000 word paper on the Iranian
Revolution in Donald Trump's voice okay
it wrote the paper sure
I said write a hip-hop song by Tupac on
the subject of this if Tupac was alive
today it wrote the okay the song If This
Was live right now what I would want to
do is to ask it ask any question from
ask a unique question of Neil deGrasse
Tyson what would you ask him to show so
so this is kind of like the the best
explanation is you go to a library
Google is I like to read books on the
subject of The Big Bang Theory here's
273 books versus this one you go to this
library and say I would like you to
write a paper for me in seventh grade
level thousand words on The Big Bang
Theory no problem in 10 seconds here's
your paper yeah yeah that's what this
thing does yeah so copywriters gone this
can write code this can write rap songs
this can write lyrics this can write
papers this can write anything to it
just declare I don't think you can write
music yet it can write Rhymes no no it
can't write no I didn't say no Awards
like if you want to do hip-hop or by the
way can you do me a favor go go to UK
education and type in chat gbt okay so
is what's this going to eliminate but
what creative what is your concern what
is your concern I'm excited about it I'm
not concerned about what are other
people's concerns a lot of people's
concern is it's going to replace jobs
for copywriters a lot of Silicon Valley
people like for example the store that
came out with New York Times type in New
York Times gbt and I put code red New
York Times GPT code red okay so this is
a recent article right there a new chat
about is a code red for Google search
business okay A lot of people are
talking about how this new wave of chat
bot like chat gbt using AI could
reinvent or even replace traditional
internet search engine okay so what's
your point I'm excited okay that's what
they're saying okay I think it's
exciting I would say yeah by the way and
one time I I tweeted this I said
um
people who cheat on exams
do so
because the system values your grade
more than the student values learning
okay so if we're worried that people
will create a a a paper
in in whatever whatever oh there it is
thank you
you found 2013 yeah yeah no I've been
I've been at this I'm going to be the
10-year anniversary of that thought
because our school system values grades
more than students value learning that's
such a powerful tweet yeah so the point
is why why would you cheat at all right
if it's only to get a grade so that the
school system thinks more highly of you
when being in school is about learning
yeah and so if you have the AI bot
create your papers you didn't learn a
thing but you got the grade this is this
is the problem we began with here in
this conversation the the value we put
on a grade is out of proportion with who
and what you actually are and become in
life so so yeah you can submit papers
like that fine
but you'll be an idiot at the end of
your school you'll get a degree because
this you fooled the system but did you
fool yourself did you fool your life no
you don't you didn't
and here's another Point guessing on an
exam
okay
uh yeah that works sometimes okay
because you might be right but guessing
in real life just shows your ignorance
period
if you don't know something say you know
I don't know I want to go find out I've
asked people questions uh who knows what
the thing no no and they'll say well let
me guess it was no no if you if you know
it or you don't the urge to guess was
because of school multiple choice tests
if you don't know the answer then guess
and then maybe you'll be right and then
we'll think highly of you for guessing
the right answer no no I'm an educator I
care that you learn stuff and yeah if
the chat bot makes people think you're
smart even though you're not who
benefits from that
I don't know
question for you here's a question for
you so let's just say you're the the
you're playing in this playground in
Venice Beach basketball you're the
sickest basketball player in Venice
Beach and everybody's gonna have to
watch you and have coffee this is just
kidding this is during covert you're
killing nobody is there yes sorry I was
just trying to be fun oh we go to covert
right afterwards but so so you're the
best basketball player I've been a
speech
everybody comes to watch on Sundays and
Joe girls are like oh my gosh you know
Joe You're great and they're fantastic
and then all of a sudden these five guys
show up and they play in the NBA and
they show up and you play against them
and they embarrass you you don't score a
single point they dunk on you all of a
sudden those same girls that were like
oh my God Joe they forgot what your name
is okay yeah you're replaced by five
guys that can do it better than you so
the only thing is about Chad gbt can it
replace that Joe who's been fantastic
now he is being replaced by AI that he
used to be important now he's just a guy
that was very smart and famous 15 years
ago yeah so you take on something else
stay flexible enough
to shift what your job Ambitions are
in the possibility that you could be
replaced
by a machine but I have an example I
personally knew a calligrapher
who drew the letters in a dictionary uh
the opening letter because the
dictionary you you start out you get to
like the letter G well the first entry
in a dictionary in the G's is the letter
G all right and so that was a
calligraphy thing that was hand done for
many many years and the company said we
need you to make a template of this okay
which she did because she was on staff
she was on payroll and then they scanned
it and then she was laid off
so
okay yeah that's sad but
you know I mean
look for other jobs that are arising
there are more jobs think about it the
330 million people in this country
and 20 years ago there were 200 million
or whatever the numbers were the point
is
all these new people who didn't exist
back then have jobs today
the job market has grown in all kinds of
dimensions in all kinds of ways
be aware of that that's why you should
never take job advice from your parents
hmm why they're stuck in the old days
they don't have any idea what's coming
around yeah in the all in the old days
you could take job advice from them
because things didn't change on a time
scale that would matter between high
school and college
but right now no it it's like getting
car advice from your father you would
never do that they would hear that Mom
what's your calligler friend uh
calligraph I haven't been what you're
doing I haven't caught up with him best
guess what do you think she's doing
don't she be retired now okay I don't
know so are you making the case for or
against Andrew Yang's famous Ubi
experiment all right so Ubi is an
interesting
solution to this if AI is making all the
money
then you know put it into the system I
would say that there might still be
things humans figure out to do that AI
doesn't really know how to do yet
and has to be trained or get better at
it or whatever so I don't know that Ubi
it's an intriguing idea it's completely
intriguing and you know what I think AIS
can't build the bridge okay or erect the
that that's a long time coming before
that happens what I think we should do
is
we should redouble double double down on
the re on the on the maintenance and
modernization of our infrastructure
those are actual human jobs
with tractors and you know yeah maybe AI
can build a prefab home with with
construction Bots but uh unique
structures that are on a hillside that
those are human being those are actual
construction workers is an AI bot going
to come in and fix your plumbing I don't
see that happening yet but if you do you
got to give them a butt crack
tape it onto the back
did we not learn during covid and all
the stimulus and the free money that
that may be printing money and free
money isn't the best solution for people
like using Ubi as an example uh allow me
to comment on that yes sir feel free
okay
what you're not considering
is
okay
um so we have this inflation all right
this past year is eight percent or
whatever it'd probably be lower this
year but still eight percent well yeah
we were printing money and so that there
was some inevitability to that so people
who don't like the politics of that
argue against that and say you shouldn't
have printed money
what was the [ __ ] alternative
you don't have money and you get kicked
out of your home and you don't have a
job
ask yourself suppose we didn't do that
and the entire industry that required
people to leave their homes and pay
money at a restaurant at a shopping mall
at every place that required people's
presence they would be out of a job and
homeless oh let's do that because that's
a better solution than having a little
bit of inflation two years after you
have a stimulus package
people don't do enough thinking about
what other consequences would have taken
place
had decisions been different
it's not just simply don't do the
package that way we won't have a little
bit of inflation a few years later
that's not really the metric that's
going on at that time
think it through now if you can say I'd
rather not have the inflation and I
don't mind millions of people kicked out
of their residence homeless with no job
then that's a decision as long as it's
an informed decision you can prefer that
it's a free country you can prefer that
and vote that way
for me we have the power to print the
money keeping people in a job
through the crisis
I think that was one of the wisest
decisions uh economic decisions that
could have been made at the time I guess
that's my opinion no and that's
perfectly fine when you say think it
through who would disagree with that you
know how like they do like in South
Korea they with the help of U.S forces
they do war games okay well if China
does this and we're going to do this and
they do a thousand different uh military
yeah these war games all these things
that happen and then different all the
time different methodologies different
why don't they do stuff like that with
like covet it's like okay cool if we're
gonna lock down the world and we can't
have money we don't have jobs and
everyone's losing their jobs all right
we're going to print money like why
doesn't the government do something like
that in terms of like war games so like
the next time covet happens because
it'll probably happen the problem is you
don't have to print all this money it
was a once in a century we hope knock on
wood well
statistically it was once in a century
the previous one was a Black Swan event
the previous one was 100 years earlier
and so uh we went a century without a
pandemic so I don't know that Solutions
we put into place today would be the
solutions we would choose a hundred
years from now in the next pandemic uh
so so yes uh the scenarios are good to
explore yes you can ask how much money
was pulled out of the stock market
um when Society closed down that was
that V uh drop that we took yeah and by
the way uh the market went back up
within 18 months it was higher than it
was the day before it dropped six months
yeah was it that quick I forgot I forgot
it was even that quick thank you the V
recovery they call it exactly are you
are you are you a fan of debate no tell
me why
because debate implies
that a person
the person who wins a debate is often
the person who is more charismatic or is
a better Communicator wow that typically
happens especially in politics
and if it's a pure matter of opinion
then a person should just simply have
their opinion if it's a matter of
objective truths this should be no
debate
about it at all it's not about debate
it's here's the evidence now let's make
the decision so for me debating is is
all about
grandstanding and idea rather than
arriving at an actual solution so to be
fair you should win 100 of debates no I
don't enter debates but what I'm saying
is if the if the
if the argument is a person who is
better at presenting arguments could oh
oh I could validate a point better than
somebody that you're an incredible uh it
should not depend on that Talent of a
person to decide what is or is not true
in a debate
really so so of course not oh my gosh no
no I'm really good at saying you know
the sky is green now let me debate that
with you and I have a Charisma and
everyone said votes and they say and I
win the debate that doesn't make the sky
green even if I won the debate that's an
exaggeration I get what you're saying
but I mean if that would have been the
case then the last election Biden
shouldn't have won because he's horrible
he's maybe one divorce on the history of
debates on National Television yes all
I'm saying is that often a debate is one
on Charisma I don't disagree more than
it is on the counter enough that a b
if a if an if an if it a subject can be
objectively analyzed
then it does not benefit from a debate
see
if it's a matter of opinions
who you want to vote for because you
prefer one policy or another
have the debate
go ahead
that's the only kind of debate I would
enter but I don't care if anyone else
has my opinions yeah I would say I'm not
going to try to convince you of my
opinions I got you well opinion is one
thing but for example like Nixon to me
and Biden are the same the moment Nixon
had to debate on the national you know
this story yeah we kind of yeah with
Canada it was like a bad situation
because right Kennedy looked good he was
10 he slapped all this stuff no he had
makeup on yeah makeup on all this stuff
and the other he didn't shape anyways
but but here's where I'm kind of going
with this during cold by the way we
forget that was one of the closest
elections in American history yeah well
anyone watching on TV I wasn't alive
then but I've studied it anyone watching
on TV thought that JFK won no but anyone
watching or listening on radio thought
Nixon won correct because
it all tells you the debate construct is
like what what are you doing here okay I
mean that's that's the American system
when it comes down to that but there's a
part of me that agrees that's my
debating opinions yeah I'm just not
going to do it because I don't care if
anyone else has it okay so let me ask
I'm not against it yeah I'm just saying
and and my school had a really good
debate team right I'm embarrassingly old
am I 30 at the point I learn that
competitive debate teams it's when you
enter the debate tournament you do not
know
in advance what side you're going to
argue
and you're handed aside to argue and I
thought to myself really
oh my gosh so you're just a trained
arguer that's what you are and then
these are people become attorneys and
attorneys become the greatest source of
presence in Congress so we have people
who are trained arguers trying to arrive
at an agreement on anything it's I'm
surprised anything ever works in
Congress at all are you for scientific
debate
so in a scientific debate here's how
that unfolds I'm in conversation with
you let's call it a debate we know you
and I know walking into that room either
I'm right and you're wrong okay you're
right and I'm wrong or we're both wrong
we know that in advance
so we start having the conversation well
what about these data what about these
days I think those datas are flawed and
here's why well how about this yes
that's a debate but you know how that
debate ends it depends where you know we
need this new data set to resolve this
difference
now let's go have a beer
I have never seen that happen in a
political debate
I've never seen nor with two lawyers in
a courtroom you know I never thought
about it that way good idea I concede
has that ever happened I think the
answer to that is no and so so because
one lawyer says wow you convinced me of
that no if you see a debate on
television will one ever just concede to
the other wow you I've never thought
about it that way yeah no they're in it
for the win whether or not they're right
yeah and I can't go there so then how
can we shoot okay so for example let me
ask you from the from what we knew at
the beginning of covid to what we know
today what do we know about the vaccine
today that we didn't know while we were
all testing it in America taking it what
have we learned now what do you mean
testing it on America there were tests
before it was released nine months is
not a long time no but it was tested
yeah the name of the average is 30 the
average is five to ten years I mean nine
months is not enough so you have to
success no you have to ask
hold on it was tested on in Trials okay
by the way I'm not claiming to be the
expert on all this I read all the same
things you have but I'm a scientist so I
read it as a scientist okay there were
trials that's what the point of phase
one two three trials are all about they
are tested enough to get data on how to
then advise the larger population yes it
was tested if you just say it wasn't
tested is it is a gap between your
awareness and understanding how things
work and what actually happened it was
tested if you wanted to be tested on
millions of people instead of thousands
you can put in for that you can say I
don't want this unless it's Millions
that's okay totally fine with me okay
I'm okay with that but but so so based
on that do you say let's keep testing it
while this virus keeps spreading okay
right so this is this is the contest
between the information you have
available to you at that moment and
what's going on outside the lab
people are dying hospitals are becoming
overloaded
so
do you say we have good data on the
thousand it's not yet at a million in
case you wanted a million are you going
to say let's still do it on another
let's wait another six months so we get
another million in here will you do that
as a public health professional no I I
would have said allow the individual to
still have a choice that's okay with a
thousand instead of a few million leave
the person have the choice not force
them to take it or else you're going to
get out of the Marines and you've been
doing this for 14 years not force them
to take it or else you have to quit your
job as a nurse there's a public health
Force versus there's a choice no
um there's a public health contract
that you have signed
implicitly as a citizen of
a country where in part we depend on
each other
for health our wealth our security and
the like and that contract is
in the best scientific evidence
available at the time
if you do not get vaccinated you will
put other people in this organization at
risk and that organization does not want
to take that risk so you do not have
this job anymore if you decline it
so
in with any public health decision
there has to be a consequence to you not
participating in that social contract is
it your job in some cases it was
but no we're not going to have the Army
bust into your home and force a needle
into your shoulder
that's not going to happen we pretty
much did that well only put your job at
risk yes yes 67 of Americans took to
covet that's forced that's not a choice
that's a that's a lot of force and and
course again pushing going on but let me
that's that's the yeah you you can't go
to the school unless you're uh
vaccinated against [ __ ] I think
that's [ __ ] that's a different
country yeah but okay would you want a
country no America is supposed to be the
one that offers the most Freedom that's
what America's supposed to be okay so
watch so so so for example so for
example if you use that argument so
somebody may say well freedom of choice
I want to choose what I want to do with
the body you're right
if you want to get an abortion your own
body if you want to get an abortion get
an abortion if I want to get the vaccine
I get to choose so you can't force if I
can't force you to get an abortion you
shouldn't be able to force it because
it's not about you it's about people you
interact with and that's the social
contract of public we don't we don't
even know if the vaccine worked or not
at the the time yes that's what the
trials are dude that's why these
childhood are you missing data out but
but let me ask you a question are we
saying only one type of scientists are
right no we're saying that the system in
place the 16 000 that's signed up no no
the system in place to test vaccines
there's an entire system that's in place
that that with review boards and all of
it and the average that's in place now
you can say you can what you can say is
I I have a better idea than all these
review boards and all these agencies and
the CDC I have a better idea here's what
you should do and that would have made
everything better okay you can put forth
that idea but what I'm saying is
in a case where you can contaminate
someone else it's not about you it's
about the collective you're assuming
Health you're assuming you're assuming
because somebody can take the vaccine uh
won't get coveted which by the way I
don't need to play the clips for you to
see it where everybody said hey if you
get it you're not going to get if you
take the vaccine you're not going to get
a Rachel Maddow Joe Biden I can give you
Fouche I can give you fit and you've
seen these clips before it's not like
you've never seen it before yeah what
happened they were wrong hold on so
so
um
The Strain evolved
okay
so that the vaccine that prevented you
from Catching covid was tuned to the
variant of covid at the time the vaccine
was denied what was designed okay
over time there were variants that arose
the vaccine provided partial protection
against the new variants enough to keep
you from dying statistically and to
basically keep you out of the hospital
allowing other people with more severe
problems to get the hospital attention
they required and so
then they would develop a a subsequent
the booster and a subsequent mixture of
the vaccine this is what happens every
year with a flu shot they look at how
the flu has evolved from one season to
the next and we have what's fortunate is
Australia tends to get the variant of
flu before we do because they get their
winter in our summer and then so we
study that have a forward projection for
it so that so these annual flu shots are
precisely out of the same idea of how
this how long have those been tested
though for years covet vaccine hasn't
been tested for it it was a it was
something we just came out but let me I
don't know what point you're making
other than it was tested you might nine
months is not you might prefer it's not
a matter of time it's a matter of it's a
matter of how many yes time matters but
the number of people is Paramount that's
the most important thing okay you don't
test it on 10 people as many people as
you can sure I think it was thousands
but is it fair to say that some of the
side effects we may not know for 5 10 15
20 years
you can't like they can't say we know
100 the side effects 10 years from now
how are you gonna know that yeah okay so
no of course we can't no so then all I'm
saying we can't know that okay but watch
um
so I have a whole chapter called risk
and reward in the book which is tries to
get sensitized people to when they make
a decision
what kind of risk are they absorbing
relative to what they're rejecting okay
and we're not very good at that at
probability and statistics or analyzing
it that's why TV commercials trying to
sell you a product don't just show you
what data they show a person speaking of
the effectiveness of the product a
single person I lost 50 pounds
the testimony of an individual should be
irrelevant to you relative to the entire
set of people who have done it and you
want to look at those statistics but
we're not good at that and advertisers
know that so they show the testimony of
an individual which is hugely potent in
a civilization where we don't think
statistically we think about eyewitness
testimony on something and somehow that
is is raised to very high level of
influence on our decisions what I'm
saying is you're not confirmed your
decision point is not I'm not going to
take the virus because five years ten
years I don't know what effect it's been
it may though some may not be
comfortable let me finish the sentence
you you
okay so you can say I don't want to take
the virus because five or ten years from
now there could be a side effect that we
don't see which is a possibility hold on
I'm trying to make a statistical Point
okay
if you say I don't want to take the
virus because it hasn't been tested for
five years and there could be some
long-term side effect that worries me
okay
in that same moment
there's the risk factor of you getting
coveted sure okay unvaccinated
80s at one point eighty seven percent of
everyone dying in the hospital of covid
was unvaccinated
Okay so
your risk choice is I'm not going to
take it because maybe somewhere down the
line something will happen and we don't
know what that is or I will risk getting
covid and if I get covered depending on
your age and other things there's a
three percent chance of me dying in the
hospital that's your choice
yes
yes but what I see people doing is they
focus on one thing and that's the
foundation of their decision but rather
than the other chance and what happens
if you get covered now you get long
covered now you have a taste buds for
for two years or whatever it is for long
covet yeah um you want a ventilator in
the hospital possibly dying like what
where is the so I looked every day once
a week I looked at the statistics how
many people getting covered what's the
rate what's the rate of hospitalization
what's the rate of deaths where is it by
State I had to look at it my board
forced me to like we're in the business
they should of course because it's data
yeah I agree on risk factors the risk of
people's lives okay for sure so nothing
is ever zero risk
yeah there's a risk that you'll grow a
third arm in 10 years because the virus
mutates within you what should the
individual should the individual not
have the right to say I don't want to
take it because you don't have the right
to contaminate someone else so if you
don't want to get who says that though
but who says that it's a it's a it's a
social contract in a modern civilization
I don't have a republican I don't have
the right to contaminate someone else in
what do you mean like so what do I do
stay home all day yeah or to go to the
beach yeah you stay you stay away from
other old people who you know from
people who are immune compromised so so
Neil So for me I'm asking you because
I'm I want to know how you process this
as a guy that's well read smart I
process the data and the data but we
didn't have enough data though no no we
didn't have enough data at any given
moment yeah there's data for you to make
a decision at any given moment sure the
date is constantly getting better and
better yeah all right so all right at
any given moment you say to yourself
okay
um
uh what happens to me if I get covered
there's a chance I'll get long covered
uh I'm certainly out for at least a week
uh and there's a chance I'll be
hospitalized and there's a chance I'll
die
[Music]
um
I take the vaccine
it mitigates this
basically entirely removing the chance
that I'm going to die essentially at my
age group and I will accept the risk
that in five years I'll grow a third arm
that's the kind of decision making that
I make
now that's just for me but on top of
that if my workplace says we don't want
you coming in unless you are vaccinated
and you might lose your job I would say
why oh because you could contaminate
someone else introducing a problem in
their own health profile
that's the public contract that's why
workers wash their hands in the
restaurant bathrooms by law yes they're
required to do so because you don't want
poop germs in your dinner that they're
preparing because our evidence showed
that that's one of the greatest places
you can spread disease is in a
restaurant with a central kitchen so
these are these are the this is the
now you want a world where you can do
whatever you want and have it influence
other people
all I'm saying is the following okay for
example statistics uh you know have you
seen the documentary that suddenly have
you learned no no okay well it's an
interesting one it's on it's on I don't
know where it's at you can find it
somewhere online yeah it's got 30
million views I think it's worth
watching actually would be curious to
know what you say about it once you
watch it the statistic then showed like
pre-covered you know 29 people athletes
in Europe died suddenly from heart
failure pre-covet pre-taking the MRNA
vaccine okay post taking the MRNA
vaccine last year
500 people suddenly had heart failures
in Europe and two-thirds died that's
documented that's not like it's a
hypothetical right okay you read
statistics like that then one has the
right to say just to be just to be
cheerful and be careful how you speak
information so so
you are describing two events
okay you're describing events that had a
temporal relationship okay before you've
established a causal relationship just
be clear that that's 100 I'm not doing
that all I'm doing is to follow it
here's all I'm doing if if if somebody
all of a sudden starts having a Breakout
okay meaning their skin starts breaking
out you're 26 years old you never had a
breakout all of a sudden you start
breaking up and the doctor says listen
man what have you been doing differently
well listen for the first time in my
life six weeks ago I started doing Deca
steroids well okay that's why it
implicates it right okay hey if somebody
all of a sudden you know is having a
hard time sleeping at night yeah man I'm
having a very hard time so let's watch
your diet well then they notice at 10 30
at night you have an iced tea and you
know lemonade and you added with this
well listen if we've been doing it for
six weeks that's why you have a hard
time just drop that don't drink that
after two o'clock I'm just making you
know saying but all I'm saying is what I
want to know is I want to put everything
on the table versus saying no no no
there's one thing we can't put on the
table and that's the cause of the
vaccine there is no way there could be
any negative impact because of vaccine
that's ludicrous has ever said that ever
about anything if you say that then the
question then becomes back for you to
say when when covet first got started I
invited so many doctors to come in to
talk about covet and I invited people on
both sides I want both sides I invited
people from both sides you know which
side would never come
the side that was for vaccine would
never ever come because they thought
they were above the average person that
Dane on the rest of us are dumb so
because of that they're not willing to
come and sit down with Scientists I
think that's arrogant so to me when I
ask you scientific debate I'm not
telling you I'm a scientist hey let me
debate with you because I'm smarter I'm
not a scientist I'm a business let's
let's do a hypothetical uh scenario
hypothetics are
um let's assume an actual cause and
effect has been has been established
okay in these in this case sure which
let's not have to see this film to know
that it cause an effect other than a
coincidence in time relative to other
things that people might have been doing
by the way alcohol consumption went up
during covid significantly okay and
alcohol is implicated in heart disease
so depression anxiety yeah people
staying at home
opioids addiction okay so though staying
at home wasn't the best decision either
what I'm saying is if after the vaccine
is available more people die of heart
failure over a time where alcohol
consumption went up as did that could be
an option yeah that's right it's a very
good that's that's all I'm saying here
but let's give it to you
let the vaccine cause this let's just
say that okay yeah and add it all up and
you get what was it 1500 Post vaccine 29
to 1500 oh
20 29.
thousands of deaths yeah okay
let's say ten thousand even
even um
all right uh
you can estimate how many deaths
the vaccine saved
during covid
okay because you look at the death
numbers drop off as people got
vaccinated it's in the tens of Millions
again you can make a decision
uh do I not want to die from covid
at this rate that occurred in this world
or do I not want to die from this
complication
from the vaccine itself so make your
decision and so you'll say I might be in
that 1500 so I'm not going to think then
you get covered and die from covet right
so you just make the decision you know
what I would say to that we know what I
would say today what would you say
here's what I would say to that I would
say perfect let me take the risk and
thank you for giving it to me that way
versus telling me it's one or the other
which is informed
fully about what the risks are but like
I said as a species we're not very good
at thinking statistically about we're
just not and when we want to we believe
we're going to be the exception and look
at the people betting on lotteries you
know they think they're going to win but
but for me but for me like you know the
moment they started uh saying you have
to put on cigarettes this the risk of
this the risk of heart failure cancer
this this that and if you still want to
smoke cigarettes guess what you got to
risk if you smoke cigarettes you may get
lung cancer right hey if you eat this if
you do this if you do that yes we've
denied your admission to the bar
a cost to that because it's a public
health issue and so right you are free
to smoke the cigarette but not in my
establishment by law
not not in your establishment by law no
problem right totally fine but that's an
example but if you want to smoke
cigarettes outside
you can live on the beach unvaccinated
that's fine Neil let me ask you this so
so what state would you say was the most
responsible during covet
stay out of state I don't know okay I
never looked so if if you're a staff no
idea okay I'm a stats guys I like stats
but I'm more financial I'm not like you
know you I understand what you're saying
that's in front I'm a baseball guy so I
like stuff I'm all about stats I love
baseball so
if we look at the stats
the media made Florida seem the most
irresponsible State that's what the
media made it look okay we're in Florida
right now you you guys do have kind of a
bad rap bad reputation on a lot of stuff
okay so so and by the way I've lived in
California 24 years five years in Texas
two years in Florida okay so you know my
background that's right 10 years in Iran
two years in Germany that's kind of my
background a couple years in the
military but if we say hey if we look at
the data the most irresponsible state
was Florida you would have heard Many
Times News telling you that when I go to
California and I would say I'm in
Florida I was like oh my God you're in
Florida oh my God that's horrible but
you know what I realize here's what I
realized if the State of Florida is so
bad
why did the MBA during black lives
matter host the playoffs in Florida
I thought they created a bubble for
themselves but why did it come here they
could have done it in Texas Texas got
plenty of places they could do it and
why they do it here I don't know but the
point is they felt safest what I'm not
going to use the NBA as a measure of
what is let's say
a lot of the Super Bowl was yeah I'll
give you another one pro-vaccine AOC for
vacation she came to Miami people from
New York and California were partying
for Miami during covet when everybody
was looking for a home during Christmas
where to go to you couldn't go to
Colorado you couldn't go to Lake Tahoe
because it sucked you had all these
other choices everybody came to Florida
I'm not gonna
I can't use that as a statistics of
safety I can't
uh I don't care who chooses where to
vacation I care what your death rates
are what your vaccination rates are what
your hospitalization rates are that that
would be an objective measure from state
to state where what state are you most
likely to die in from covid that's a
statistic I would pay attention to what
state has the least hospital beds to
accommodate those who are sick from
covet even if they're not going to die
from covet I would want to know that I'm
not gonna
base a decision on whether the NBA chose
to put their bubble in the state well
statistically in New York and California
does not look good statistically New
York and California and they're supposed
to be the most responsible ones those
two states didn't look good all I'm
saying is from my end in a space where I
sit there and I listen to you and I
learn I say oh my gosh okay I had no
clue about that that was brilliant
that's interesting let me go research
let me go look at this let me I'm a guy
that likes debate of experts in two
different sides and let them make the
argument and I'm mature enough to know
the better salesman doesn't necessarily
have the better argument but let me just
say that I'm there's nothing I've said
in the last half hour that is a debating
Point all I'm telling you well you can
debate whether you should still be able
to work and put other workers at risk
for not having vaccinated that's a you
can debate that yeah
in the context of Public Health
that's a risk factor that we don't want
to introduce to other people because of
your decisions that's a public health
issue that's been going on basically for
a hundred and something years since you
know the uh the the what's the who's the
woman who uh some famous medic case a
person who spread what's it
uh what what is that case recently no no
100 years ago oh it created a whole wave
of sanitation rules and things for
public health sake but anyway the the
point is it's I want to make sure you
know you can focus on the 1500 people
who died after the vaccine Mary Mallon
um about the history of typhoid fever
yep typhoon Mary yes thank you yeah okay
I didn't know her last name yeah I
thought typhoid was her first name
typhoid marriage
so uh so it's simply a matter of
if you're saying you don't want to be in
the 2000 whatever the number is who died
after the vaccine from heart failure at
the peak of your physical career
not totally necessarily factoring in all
the other abuses that went on over that
time that may have contributed to it
instead you want to take the risk of
covid and not be one of the 20 million
people who would have died and didn't
right so so I just want you to have the
statistics in front of you and it seems
to me most people would in most cases
choose the path
that reduces their chance of death
but by the way I don't disagree that's
why I'm not debating
but this part of what you're saying I'm
I'm 100 with you but this is it's not a
matter of being with me it's just are
you with no decision but what is a
rational statistical but this position
is not an arrogant position this
position is kind of like when you're
sitting there and a doc and you tell the
doctor sadak what do I do do I get the
search like we have one of my good
friends right now is getting a brain
surgery in the next couple weeks she's
she's afraid now she believes in God so
faith is kind of common or down but
she's afraid okay
the doctor says there's a 10 chance
you're not going to make it do you want
to for the rest of your life live having
to take that medication with the side
effects or do you want to do the surgery
the individual is making a decision to
get the surgery she knows the chances is
what 10 you know what I say to that hey
at least I know the risk versus no if
you take this you won't get anything
propaganda selling me this like what's
the three things that you say there's
three different types of truth right
subjective truth personal truth and
political truth exactly that's the one I
have a problem with and I agree with you
we all and that's the part I have a
problem with I I'm the personal truth
let's debate have fun with it great let
the audience yeah yeah you want to
debate debate personal truth exactly
that's cool Kirker Picard you know yes
whatever yes but that's a Star Trek
reference dude who let him in I'm sorry
let him in they've been asking that
question for years
the political truth I think is what
brought a lot of uh uh division in
households companies different places of
course I think that's what happened last
two and a half years specifically with
that and you know this like you took it
you didn't take it you're part of
political party like you may be
positioning me right statistically that
is the correct statement yeah
statistically it was but what was
interesting is that people with no
college degree these uh
took the vaccine less than those with
bachelor's degrees but then MBA was the
least which is kind of funny MBA people
took the least amount of extra percent
sociology yeah interesting sociology
statistics can I ask a follow-up on this
because I think this is the question
that you're really asking but we're
using covet as like a as an example as a
case example because I think what you're
asking ultimately is the question of
power versus choice right or or Force
versus choice so like on one hand on one
end of the spectrum what you're talking
about is the social contract uh the
collectivism the the greater good on one
hand doing the right thing protect your
neighbor but on the other hand you know
one would argue like sort of the the
woven in fabric of America is this
rugged individualism being able to make
your own choices and being self-reliant
so if I'll go move to a cabin in the
woods and don't get vaccinated no one
will stop you from doing that but is is
that what rugged individualism means
individualism means that to me
individual means you matter more than
anyone else around you in the decisions
you make about your life
and so to me that's what individualism
is and so how do we
how do we juxtapose that with the rest
of society
that doesn't want to
the disease you might carry and give to
them you like I said just move into a
log cabin
until until the disease washes over and
then wait till the rest of us have herd
immunity and then you won't get it and
you you'll be just fine let us get the
herd immunity for you we'd rather do
that for the person who is immune
compromised who can't get the vaccine
but in America in a in a freedom woven
into our identity America Merc
apostrophe M America I'm right there
with you so I don't have any problem
thinking that way but yeah I I'm not
going to let you in the room with my
immune compromised nephew who can't get
the vaccine because his immune system
won't allow it because he has some other
condition so you that he's relying on
the I don't have such a nephew but they
exist
um I was going to say give him my best
thank you even for thinking that way
that the herd immunity is you get enough
vaccinations within that even if the
virus shows up it can't propagate yeah
because the next person it hits is
resistant to it and so what's what
Neil what's the most unattractive and
attractive quality to you if you were to
say the most attractive quality in a
human being versus unattractive what
would you say that I don't I don't have
an opinion okay so so I think I have a a
pretty good sense of humor and I noticed
a lot I know you do like you like humor
so I I'd like I think you're very I like
making people smile yeah especially if I
can have them smile while they're
learning then you'll learn that much
more it's called valuetainment you're
bringing that value I love them it's
called valuetainment No but I see what
you did there yeah but but I I I don't
it's not for me to judge you don't want
to ask that question you know why I
asked that question the reason why I
asked that question is you know because
it's very annoying when somebody just
thinks they know everything 100
certainty and you're dumb and you don't
know it and because of that you better
or else you don't care about other
people and that's that's the part about
the force versus the choice thing we're
talking about here and that was felt a
lot yeah
it was a wee versus they mentality which
by the way I've taken probably more
vaccines than 99 of pay I was in the
military we took God knows how many
vaccines it was more if you would have
taken me and said here's your options
here's what you got I may have
entertained more than another way of
forcing it down my throat last topic
before we were into your arm yeah that's
true that's a bad way to take the shot
on your throat it's probably not a good
idea that visualization is not a good
visualization last stop but before we
wrap up how much how much I've seen you
say you were talking to somebody from uh
some China media company and you were
talking about us and China or Frenemies
right you know friends and enemies and
all that stuff and you said you know the
the competition to go back to the Moon
we're not winning it China's winning it
right you were talking about how uh on
the way it's not I don't think that's
what I said but I can see how one can
think that they're winning it that I can
see how that but go on okay yeah so what
I think what I said was
the only reason why we're going back to
the moon now is upon seeing China's
plans to go to the Moon
because otherwise we could have done
this 30 40 years ago we could have
stayed on the moon there's a lot of
things we could have done and didn't and
all of a sudden we're going back to the
moon and it's the right and everyone
feels good about it and you part the
curtains and move the pages look behind
the the the the beads and there is the
motivation for it as Americans in spite
of our own memory of ourselves we are
much better reacting
two threats then we are
being proactive let me not say threats
competition is the way you put I think
let me just be really specific yeah
we remember ourselves as being space
pioneers and we're in Florida we're at
all the launches were and but really we
were reactive to the progress made in
the Soviet Union rather than proactive
they had the first satellite the first
non-human animal the first human they're
the first woman they're the first
dark-skinned person a Cuban a Cuban
communist they had the first space
station they had they beat us at
practically everything and we said well
how what what can we do to let's go to
the Moon all right so we went to the
Moon
beat enemy say we win
even though they had beaten Us in every
other metric we got to say we win and
then we saw they're not going to the
moon so we abandoned the program yeah so
we'd like to think we're explorers we're
Americans that's why we didn't know we
did it because we were scared Witness
so here's China saying we're going to
put some folks on the moon if they've
made good on every space promise they
have made and all of a sudden we have
renewed interest in going to the Moon
gotta love it I don't want to be so
naive as to think we just decided it
just on a lark that that's the point I
was making no and and again if anybody
wants to watch a clip you can go find it
just type in Neil deGrasse Tyson he can
put Frenemy China and you'll see it's a
great clips like 30 minutes I highly
recommend people watching it you know I
haven't re-seen it so thank you I think
it's really insightful the way you're
explaining the fact that competition
even amongst governments is good because
it makes us do it was it was a very
interesting point being made about it it
can accelerate progress I agree yeah
what how much in maybe your answer to
this may be different than some of the
rest of us you know the question about
what keeps you up at night yeah what
keeps you up at night for a mother with
a newborn it's the baby for a guy with a
starter not really true it's the startup
for a guy who's a podcaster who's got a
big interview the next day and it's the
best guess he's ever had in five years
and he's thinking this is going to be
it's the interview for the guy that's
about to raise capital and he's got it's
the guy he's raising Capital with what
keeps you up at night in regards not
personal life where it's like my
daughters my my wife my family my this
in regards to enemies America may have
what keeps you up at night
oh
um
yeah I don't those aren't the kind of
thoughts I have
uh
you look around the world there are
always warring factions
but I try to I try to
put it on a scale
and on that scale
you know today there's conflict in the
world and sometimes if it's armed
conflict people die this sort of thing
of course in Ukraine and Russia and this
sort of thing
when I look back to the second world war
between 1939 and 1945.
1 000 people were killed per hour
of every hour between 1939 and 1945.
you want to talk about a time of
violence
there is no
comparison to that period
we look back on it so we won the war and
we had the technology and it's
remembered differently
from the Carnage that that caused
and so when I look around and I see
Carnage in the world and I index it to
that I say to myself we're we're in a
relatively safe world
which is hard It's A Hard Sell if you're
the country being invaded and bombed you
know uh no question but so so so that's
why it's it's a hard conversation to
have but
um I think it matters people say we're
in the most racist time ever no we're
not objectively I have stories from my
parents I have stories from my life I
have metrics for this yeah there's still
problems
but you know how to measure this here's
how you do it let's say you are
uh you're on the gender Spectrum or
you're a person of color or you're
you're a woman
and you have a time machine
and someone says and I talk about this
in the book I say here's a time machine
you can have access to anytime
in the history of civilization
where would you go
and and choose a time where you'll be
better off than you are today
there is no time you're going nowhere
you're going nowhere send me to the
Future because the Arc of progress The
Arc of morality bends towards progress
and
nowhere
nowhere at all
if you're gay you can say let me go back
Clinton was a good prayer oh wait a
minute that was the don't ask don't tell
error that was AIDS pervasive killing
everyone Eric okay right right
yeah so our media has a tendency news
media has a tendency to focus on all
that is bad and leave you with the
impression that everything is bad
without the metric of
well some things are better
many most things are better why don't we
focus on that and do more of that
rather than
become sad over the things that are
bad
did that sentence come out such a
powerful point right right right
everything you're saying something we
are doing some things that are good
that's why there is progress what you're
saying is we're living in the best time
humanity has ever seen ever ever ever
that's such a necessary message ever and
even with the violence yes especially in
these days the violence against trans
people okay
um
all right yes
go back in time
the existence of trans people was even
denied okay oh you have a mental
condition was it was 1987 before the
American Psychiatric association removed
homosexuality as a mental disorder from
their catalog
87 that's not for old folks that's not
all that long ago we remember those
times
so yeah there's problems today
well I'm not going to back to any time
in the past you know there's a lot of
like younger folks that don't remember
that you know I see a lot of these gen Z
types right right young what would your
message be to young people even let's
stay on this topic that's what we're
saying no no I'm staying on this topic
here I'm staying on the topic of what's
keeping you up at night we're not going
to younger people
want me to think about sort of the
violence in the world and when I reflect
on the world I think of how we are not
killing a thousand people per hour in
Warfare with the World at War I I think
about that I think about the fact that
yes a taxi does pick me up today
even though I'm going north in Manhattan
where Harlem is
and whereas 15 years ago they would not
or at least two and four would not I can
always wait for one to pick me up I I
think about
um
the occasions when I was coming up where
I would just simply be ignored this is
something that women experience all the
time with men yeah it's a it's something
that uh the black community was
experienced with white white if you have
expertise you're just ignored
that has changed
now you have black experts on television
talking about things that have nothing
to do with being black we need an expert
on this International how often do you
talk about this I know it's never no how
often never hardly ever why don't you
though because then I become the person
who talks about black things and I don't
want to be that person to you I want to
be the astrophysicist who tells you
about the universe and the James Webb
Space Telescope and all the rest of this
it shows it is sometimes I think uh uh
you know we have a life experience that
we have been granted with to use as a
way to give a different perspective to
people at a time that's necessary to
unify plenty of other black people to
give exactly that same but they don't
have your voices they don't have you but
by the way what I want to say is I
appreciate you saying that I got an
example I was in South Africa in 1992.
yeah okay barely the vote South Africa
South Africa and I'm walking the street
I'm not a small person I'm talking and
there are two a couple coming towards me
South Africa they're white
they did not even look up they're just
looking down talking to each other it
was fully expected that I would part
around them for them to keep walking
forward yeah
it wasn't even oh let's just both take a
slight half step to the side as you pass
one another no that is not what happened
and I at another time I'm in a
convenience store and I put the money
down and the krugerrands and the and the
gum or whatever I was buying while I'm
there in that little open section of the
heavily overstuffed
purchase area someone comes up behind me
puts something down
fully expecting that they're going to be
taken next when I am standing there like
I said I'm not a small person this is
South Africa and I realized okay
they still have a way to go because
they haven't even graduated
to the point of noticing me and then
calling me names
they were still in a state where I did
not exist and I was irrelevant and then
I look at those images from the 1950s of
the police dogs and the and the the
people when the little school children
are trying to go into the high school
and I say wow
that's an advance over everything
completely ignored all right we look at
the Arc of how what it takes for people
to to to to achieve equality and equity
and all the things that uh that the
promised land should give us all I said
to myself okay South Africa has a long
way to go
because they were they were not even
calling me the n-word
and now I began to look at the n-word as
oh okay you at least know I'm here that
would that would have been progress is
what your progress
progress you know what I'm so to answer
your question I don't I I don't think
about that but by the way you don't you
don't come across as a person that does
think about that yeah well thank you and
I mean it in the most uh positive way
because I feel you're optimistic about
the future and grateful that you come
correct you come that way into kind of
your energy you feel that energy from
you some some people are concerned about
Tick Tock and the influence over Tick
Tock and you know how China's using now
you've seen some articles Forbes you've
seen it maybe this is not a topic that
you study yourself no it's not your
world because I was on the board of the
Pentagon that advised the president's on
this fantastic and then it became a new
story should Tick Tock be banned or
should we leave it in America should it
be banned so so with whatever other
reason one might object to tick tock the
fact that it's a Chinese company and the
history of this exercise is that China
has typically has back doors into access
and who you are and what you're doing
um that is that is a natural state of
their government to have that kind of
access to their people by the way
our companies and our own government has
kind of that same access to us except
it's our own government yeah exactly so
don't look at this is that some
specialized sure all right Facebook
knows everything there is to know about
you I'm not reading that yeah so
um I would be in favor and I don't I
haven't followed this lately the latest
after we've first advised Trump on this
this in fact a few years ago it was the
um
it was a one that was a brand new board
of the Pentagon um a defense Innovation
board we're Innovative things that were
happening in the world to keep you
um uh to keep you
uh to keep the military at the Forefront
of what they need to know and do so you
can have a military that is uh ready for
the 21st century and whatever it
delivers so the point is the I could
imagine just if they maybe they've
already done this I don't know
to split the company and just have a
tick tock America that has no ties back
to China although they try to do that
they try to force them to sell right
otherwise or other than maybe an annual
you know board meeting or something make
sure the mission statements are aligned
I I I wouldn't have any problem with
that yeah but that way we would control
the back end yeah and then and then the
question becomes it's kind of like
saying to follow which is kind of weird
imagine if Tick Tock USA was allowed to
be bought by Elon Musk holy [ __ ] now
that's a crazy situation right if that
were to happen if they allowed somebody
liked him like him to buy because the
first thing he's going to do is you want
to talk about Twitter files it becomes
Tick Tock files times a thousand every
day
yeah I want you to see this so this is
uh make the video bigger so this is a
guy it doesn't matter because you're not
going to see his face this guy Neil Shen
is a first go to his Wikipedia who Neil
Shannon is he's a four billion Auto guy
and Neil Shan is being interviewed here
by
guru's Wikipedia he sits on Sequoia yep
go to right there zoom into his uh
profile Nielsen is a member of the tent
cppcc National Committee vice president
professional committee Venture Capital
fund of asset management association of
China member of Hong Kong uh SAR chief
executive advisor panel and Manchester
anyways
he's a very connected guy and he's a
four billion Auto guy now watch this
interviewer asks a very basic question
but watch how he defines Ai and why
China is better than us and yeah I just
want to get your reaction on this go for
it so it's a minute half clip in fact
fundamentally what is AI in the whole
science field it's mathematics and
statistics and China has a very strong
talent in these two areas if you've got
a smile on your face as if to say yeah
we can do that I mean I'm a prime as
major when I was undergrad in China and
there are many of my talented you know
alums and colleagues I'm pretty sure
they could do well so you've got the
talent and you've got the data is the
environment for getting hold of that
data easier in in China as the
regulatory environment does that make
life easier because in Europe for
example we have quite strict rules about
privacy and and so forth well I think
privacy and protections is always a
issue and whether it's in UK or whether
in U.S or within China I think there are
different sectors in China have
different regulations reducing those
regulations are very important and
relevant but in general I think there's
just more data point but there is surely
a danger that AI can be used as a tool
of suppression and surveillance and I'm
going to stick my neck out here and say
in an authoritarian country such as
China does that worry you at all I don't
think so watch this
I mean can you just engage with the
question of you know a bit because it is
clearly you know to say we collect data
everywhere but when you are not prepared
to talk about that it could make the
censorship of the internet easier
couldn't it
no
silence I mean is it broadly true
understand that you just don't want to
talk about the implications for and more
authoritarian Society
awkward I'll just leave a little bit of
a hole around that
yeah we'll move on
um so he went from very talkative to
silent Island yeah they asked me about
it go off script there yeah there you go
I agree with or ruffle a little bit of
feather you know what he's saying no no
I think it's what he's saying go off
script
and Off Script is
a question that wasn't scripted that
sounds like yeah yeah but he's right
that the AI can process
information
manifold faster than any other kind of
way you would ever analyze information
and yeah you can do whatever you wanted
with it you can suppress you can enhance
you can cause people to get elected or
Not Elected by influencing what they see
what they think what they feel
and so yeah
that's a possible future of AI in the
hands of people who are nefarious in
their intent that's the part about AI
that that uh you know sometimes like we
were talking about earlier like what are
you worried about what do you think is
going to happen with this that you know
we're like oh we're thinking about is oh
my God we may lose our jobs right I was
like ah no the reason our biggest
problem
that's not she'll pick this problem
because if the enemy like a China knows
how to use AI they can completely
reshape the way of thinking for your
nation by the way
by the way China has a minister of AI
the United Arab Emirates has a minister
Rob can you pull this up so these these
would this is our equivalent of a
cabinet yeah we do not have administer
of AI why do we not have one
this is America
if you visit other countries they see
know and care about the future of AI on
a level now of course the military has
an AI group that are thinking deeply
about how that would be invoked uh on my
board we put because AI would come under
the Innovation
umbrella and our board we put uh
parameters about how the military would
ever use AI in a dis in what would be a
lethal decision
and what kind of should there be a human
in the loop the AI would not be making
that decision autonomously so we put in
a system of Ethics related to it so with
so it's not like no one in our
government is thinking about it but
imagine if there wasn't a cabinet post a
a secretary of AI that would change
people's awareness of its value to the
governance of this nation and what it
might be doing in other nations but we
haven't and we're not we're arguing
about whether humans are warming the
Earth okay this is what's going on in
America are we
laughs
sorry I laughed at him yes okay wouldn't
be the first or last nail to graduate
they're very very very interesting what
you just said though very interesting
what you just said so so you're saying
if we have if we had to create a
priority of what to study as a nation to
create security and safety for its
people
you're you're saying the the climate
change wouldn't be in your top five
you you would put AI it sounds like
you're saying AI studying something of
the space no no I wouldn't rank them I
just do them all you don't have to rank
things but you got to kind of budget
like you know how you said one time you
know our budget for space is 0.4 of one
percent which is let me break this
remember the one you broke that I
thought I was like so out of the
whatever budget we got point four
percent of every dollar yeah if you cut
a dollar bill yeah point four percent of
it doesn't even get you into the ink
that's just the border on the edge yeah
yeah so a form of where we put our money
as a form of sin was the price yes of
course but I'm just saying I don't need
to put it in one place and not another
place if you can put it in both places
well if you could put more resources in
one place what would it be if you could
put in this country right now yeah yeah
um on
sources of energy that are renewable
which would include Fusion nuclear
fusion as we had the ignition test just
a couple of weeks ago successful at the
Lawrence Livermore Labs that's a
basically clean energy just have to
figure out how to contain it and
throttle it and use it in ways we need
so that I would do that I would also
consider turning the solar system into
our backyard because Rare Earth elements
for example that are causing some
geopolitical tension and conflict access
to them for all of our modern day
Electronics they're asteroids that have
nothing but rare Earth elements in them
in fact they're common asteroid elements
so the asteroids have pre-sifted these
ingredients
out there in space when they all formed
and so uh yeah there's the Breakthrough
you have up there on the on the chart so
so yeah I would do that because that has
a much longer value time to civilization
than anything else we're debating today
and I'd throw in I I I'd redouble I
double down on whether
quantum entanglement can matter in any
important way and Quantum Computing for
sure quantum entanglement is that
something Jada Pinkett knows what
kind of thing Will Smith I thought you
said what is quantum Quantum entangle
it's a whole thing yeah it's it's you
have two particles created together then
you separate them you make a measurement
on one that instantaneously manifests in
the other got faster than the speed of
light so it's very spooky action at a
distance so it's a frontier of quantum
physics and it will be exploited in
Quantum Computing so I would say Quantum
Computing these are Frontiers that can
transform how we live and what we do hmm
okay there you go so do that until we go
into the book and the show tonight and
we'll wrap it up cool I just had a
question it was more related face
related yeah relationship oh really
gonna ask me space questions
I don't know I don't know if you like
talking about space really but I I do
like the fact that you both got uh three
uh letters in you know pbd NDG okay um
right uh Neil NDT NDT it's my bad uh
Neil deGrasse Tyson
um how many you I've heard you talk
about this before about how many
universes there are and that we exist in
multiple universes how many Neil
deGrasse Tysons how many Patrick Bet
Davids how many atoms saws things are
there in the entire universe well no so
there's the Multiverse and then the
Multiverse concept which has very strong
theoretical reasons to think it's real
even though we've not measured one yet
but it comes out of equations that are
otherwise working
splendidly for us in this universe you
go back to the beginning of time the big
bang and the equation the equations that
generate our universe give us multiple
universes so it's a fascinating Frontier
in physics it would give so many
universes
that every combination of atoms will be
realized in those universes including
combinations of atoms that would exactly
duplicate this universe or maybe I'm the
host and you're the guest or I or you
have an evil mustache or something or
whatever he did have a goatee last year
one week
oh so you did have that was your other
person in this universe I'm the only
Middle Eastern that can't grow full-on
beard I don't have a lot of facial hair
it doesn't have in it it is my dad is
like stacked like and he got hair
growing up out of your shirt but you
can't grow it on your face amazing okay
uh so for the fifth grader and me
explain what that means how many Neil
degrass okay so you'd have all these
other universes with
all Planet Stars playing out there might
be one that looks like Earth that has
life like that that evolved just the way
we did with an asteroid that took out
the dinosaurs that could happen in
duplicate
that doesn't mean it's you
because we've already done that
experiment
they're called twins your twin is
genetically identical to you but it's
not you
so just because it's someone else who's
genetically identical to you in the
universe doesn't make it you hmm
so the people who want this as some form
of eternal life no there's no evidence
to think that that's what's how that
would actually play out wow
so there's no evil there might be an
evil PVD with a fake mustache but
there's only one PVD and it's an
interesting indie film called Another
Earth
which I recommend where we discover
another Earth exactly opposite our orbit
and everything is identical
until the Two Earths communicated with
each other he was hoping
he's kind of disappointed yeah anyways
it's like that tell us about your your
new book new book that came out Starry
Messenger story messenger yeah just a
few months ago it's it's my attempt to
show everyone what the world looks like
when you're scientifically literate and
you have a cosmic perspective on it so
it's called Cosmic perspectives it's
starting messenger Cosmic perspectives
on civilization
and so there are chapters in there that
yeah there's one on risk and reward it
reminds you us that we are really bad at
statistics
and there's an entire industry that
exists knowing this fact and they're
called casinos
okay yeah people trying to roll dice and
they need High numbers so they roll the
dice harder to try to get high numbers
or they roll it softer if they want a
low number they're betting on seven on
the roulette table and I said why are
you betting on it like six times in a
row let's do I say why do you think it's
due well because look at the previous
roles and no it's not due
this is an an inability to understand
probability and statistics and I think
it's
a failure of the wiring of the human
species brain
do you realize the first time anyone
ever took an average of numbers
realizing that would be a good idea
that was not until like the late 1700s
calculus had already been developed uh
geometry algebra all of that and it was
a late 18th when our country was being
born someone said you know maybe I'll
take an average and see if that's good
late late and so that tells me that
statistics is not a natural way it's
even post Newton poster yes and he's the
guy that started
correct yeah yeah the man birth calculus
and taking an average
it's completely crazy so that tells me
it hints to me that
statistics is not a native way we ever
think about anything
and so it's a struggle to then replace
your emotional interpretation of what's
going on with a statistical one again
that gets back to the early point about
advertisers they will give an emotional
case rather than just simply show a bar
chart
I want to see a bar chart is this the
best product and then there's the data
then fine I don't need someone tearing
up in the screen telling me how much
they love the product just give me the
data but they know that doesn't work
and so here's what's interesting do you
know where Lottery money goes to
it fun schools it's fun schools so let's
look at the school curriculum oh there's
no statistics taught Jesus right it's
like a it's like it's an elective or
something but it's not part of the
Reading Writing arithmetic so I wonder
why there's no statistic because if they
taught statistics you would know not to
play those they would tell you not
so this is my only conspiracy theory
I've ever had that the states
intentionally don't teach you statistics
so that you become an adult Lottery
player so they can still get the money
you know there's a lot more conspiracy
theories to follow except that one no it
is what it is that one actually has some
validity that's the only one I'm
sticking to all right
you give me one conspiracy theory that's
that's the one wow so that's there's a
whole chapter on that there's a chapter
on color and Race So I go there in there
there's one on meat eaters and
vegetarians these are worrying factions
in society where people dig their heels
in with strongly held opinions and I
just say look here's what that looks
like to a scientist and here's what it
would look like coming from above and
often the opinions just evaporate
they just I'll give an example in the
vegetarian meat eater chapter okay uh
you we all know vegetarians and one of
them some might be vegetarian so they
just don't want to kill animals okay all
right
fine so they have my Humane mouse trap
in their basement you trap the mouse and
then what do you do with after you
capture it
eat it
what do they do after they capture the
mouse they let it go they take it back
out to the woods to let it go and then
it comes back in wait wait out to the
woods where it is basically guaranteed
to be swallowed whole by an owl or
picked apart by a predator bird or eaten
by a fox or any manner of Woodland
predators and the average life
expectancy of a mouse in the wild is
about 18 months
so the safest thing for the mouse
is to leave it in your basement
where it could live up to six years on
full natural life but that's not what
happens
so the idea that you you want to
preserve life and you don't want to kill
it and you take it out and put it in the
wild where it's guaranteed to be killed
that that person possibly hasn't fully
thought that through
continuing they're living in a house
made of the wood from 50 trees typically
trees that would have lived a hundred
years each of those trees was home to
birds to squirrels to insects to Funk to
mushrooms to all manner of life forms
are being sustained on each one of those
trees and each one of those 50 trees
that was cut down to build your house to
make the floorboards the two by fours
the structural members the siding each
one of those trees
produces
15 times the mass of the mouse in oxygen
every day
so what do you think nature cares more
about
tree
or the one ounce Mouse
think about that
what what has greater value to the
ecosystem
the mouse you saved or the tricky treat
the I I would think so of course but I
don't want to force that opinion on
people but just when you analyze it this
that's a cosmic perspective on decisions
that you're making
I don't see you not buying a wooden
house
because you're worried about the trees
that were made from it
so what it comes down to at some level
and how about the people who buy line
caught tuna do you know why they do that
because if it's not line caught it's
probably caught in a net a net dragging
sometimes brings in a dolphin which are
air breathing and then they suffocate
and die
all right so I don't really want to kill
dolphins
so they buy line so I'm thinking all
right
save the dolphin but what about the tuna
you're eating the tuna all right who
cares about the tuna they only care
about the dog they only care about well
why do you only care about the dolphin
because they've got a good personality
okay wait because it's they're cute and
they're beautiful but wait a minute if
you're eating meat you're probably also
eating cow and pig and lamb that are
also mammals
okay so so I what I try to do in the
book
is expose your opinion to other ways of
looking at what is it what it is you're
doing when you're done I don't want to
stop you from doing what you're doing
but if you do it I want it to be fully
informed and it's a whole other chapter
on conflict and resolution where these
tropes that liberals lob onto right
Wingers you know say oh the everyone on
the right is anti-science and they're
this and they cite the denial of climate
change which is an existential threat
that's definitely a denial of some or
all mainstream science also occasionally
there's denial of evolution that
typically is the extreme religious group
okay so the Liberals want to feel like
they have the high road but they don't
because let's look for who is taking
homeop homeopathic medicine that is
deeply within the in the liberal
Community this medicine that has no
Curative molecules in it at all having
been diluted into that state so there's
like feather energy and chakra
realignment and all manner
of thinking and philosophies that are
deeply embedded in the liberal world
view and to embrace
them requires you reject some or all
mainstream science associated with it it
requires that and so therefore the
liberal cannot claim The High Ground
this includes attitudes towards GMOs for
example if you look at
um
scientists the percentage of scientists
who are all in for GMOs it closely
matches the percentage of
of
um Republicans who are all in for GMOs
and the percentage of liberals who are
in for GMOs is way less
so what's happening here they'll cite
well because of big Pharma and this and
that whatever but they're not aligned
with the science on it that's my point
if you want to say you're with a
scientist then you be with the scientist
on GMOs and they're not all right so it
requires rejection of some or all
mainstream science so the Trope they're
anti-science and we're not is false
objectively false statistically in the
communities how about the one about
being Family Values that's a common
Trope law against liberals by
conservatives
well wait a minute what would be a
measure of family value how about
staying married how about that do you
know the state with the lowest divorce
rate in the country it's Massachusetts
by far the lowest divorce rate
do you know the highest divorce rate
it's in the book something like eight
out of the ten highest divorce rate
states
voted red in the last elections hmm
how about teenage pregnancies out of
wedlock present pregnancy and teenage
pregnancies the
red States lead the pack in those
numbers
the only presidents of the United States
to have ever been divorced have been
Republican presidents
and that's of course Trump Reagan and
Ronald Reagan so who are you to say and
claim the high road of family values
here when certain objective measures
argue against it
and so so what I'm saying is you can
cherry pick it and say oh the Liberals
they're into like loose sex or whatever
you cherry pick that because Liberals
are staying married longer than you are
okay so in there I'm just approaching
all these as a scientist would look at
the data look at the evidence you might
have bias against and now let me show it
to you reveal it to you so there's a
chapter on gender and identity a chapter
on on life and death
body and mind
truth and beauty
hmm
is all this that you're saying I'm
looking at the website right now by the
way divorce rates you know who's at the
top who's at the lowest you look at the
highest divorce rate State it's a red
State it's been read every for every
major election Arkansas Arkansas
Oklahoma Nevada New Mexico and the
lowest one is Maine DC Dakota
Pennsylvania New York Illinois
Massachusetts should be in there
Massachusetts is on that list as well
yes yeah very interesting yeah very yeah
it's contradictions of both sides
correct say relax correct because they
repeat it and want you to then think
it's true is it cognitive dissonance or
is it hypocrisy it's it's
cognitive bias I don't say dissonance
it's just bias you want something to be
true so you repeat it often enough until
you people who follow you think it's
true it's like saying we live in a
Christian Nation that's actually an
objectively false statement repeated
enough that you get enough people saying
it on political platforms and uh talk
shows in all manner of things
long uh I don't know if you know Reza
Islam yes I do yeah he believes U.S is a
judeo Christian that's a joke between us
like oh okay if he's watching this right
now
it's mine yeah yeah if he can if he's
out on you he can say it but but there's
no mention of Jesus in our constitution
there's not even mention of God
in the document that forms our country
you would think if we knew we were
self-aware as a Christian Nation there'd
be some references to Jesus who's the
foundation of Christianity but there
isn't there's one mention of God in the
Constitution but a very minor one it's
extremely minor what was it at the very
end
Anno Domini 1789.
that's the only mention which is the
tradition of it's A.D that's the year so
you put it in so and there are there's
other evidence and uh so so in other
words buy the book okay
uh description as well oh
by the way I
all tonight don't you talk about your
show tonight put in a plug for it
I did the audiobook
I'm buying the audio no no if you get
stuck in traffic that's the way I I
calculated how long it would take to
hear the audiobook in Los Angeles yeah
stuck in traffic one day
it's a three-day audiobook 405 freeway
in LA traffic black matter yeah yeah
Dark Matter Dark Matter yeah so so tell
us about tonight
yeah it's like we're live right now yeah
tonight I'm in I'm in Fort Lauderdale at
the Broward Center nice giving a public
talk to like thousands of people on one
of my favorite subjects which is it's
titled an astrophysicist goes to the
movies I love that the sequel and it's
it's like dozens of movie clips all
kinds of movie clips well I highlight
the science they got right
if they got it right and the science
they got wrong movies like this movie's
like like
um Harry Potter is in there yeah there's
The Wizard of Oz there's love story
there's where do I begin to tell a story
of how where do I begin I would sing it
but I don't have your voice yeah no
you've got that PVD so so it's one of my
funnest subjects to talk about and the
audiences also love it because they've
all seen these movies typically and and
oh god
um so oh the Top Gun movie I tweeted
about that that's not in tonight I might
mention it yeah the top Tom Gunn ejects
at Mach 10.5 and and just walks back to
base with a slightly dirty face
uh he would have been squashed by the
shock waves at Mach 10.5 the way a bug
hits a windshield wow
yeah he wouldn't have survived a
fraction of a second ejecting
from by the way do you know why
airplanes have pointy noses that go
faster than sound because you need to
because the air does not part for you
you have to cleave the air because
you're moving faster through the air
then the air can tell other air
molecules that you're doing that
because the air molecules communicate
with each other at the speed of sound if
you're moving through it faster than the
speed of sound you have to cleave the
air
to make that happen and so all your your
your front surfaces have to be pointy if
he ejects he is in no such shape or
vehicle and he basically is blown apart
by the he's going 7 000 miles an hour he
doesn't survive this what a movie though
okay what a movie that was by the way
did you like Avatar
so I saw it I thought it was I felt a
little long okay
um I thought it was 40 minutes long yeah
I'm being serious with you yeah
seriously three hours and 12 minutes you
could have done it in two and a half
hours yeah so here's here's my issue
with it I I prefer the first avatar only
because there was much more discussion
about the culture of the of the peoples
and I like learning about the little USB
ponytail that connects to the plants and
the Animals I thought maybe a follow-on
movie would get deeper into that rather
than just be about Warfare you know
three and four yeah I know yeah it was
all happening at the same time oh really
anyways gang this was a blast the book
below order it read it uh contradictions
on both sides if you're interested it
doesn't lean you think it's leaning one
way or not it doesn't I felt that it's
not it's not like it's going which is
great in America yeah as it should be oh
yeah red not blue red white and blue no
no the purple okay during the state it
used to be people now it's red anyways
uh Neil oh by the way this anti-vaxx
thing yeah the Liberals were the OG
anti-vaxxers because they all didn't
trust big Pharma and all the rest that's
why it's confusing what happened to them
and then under Trump there was this
freedom I don't I don't think that and
then the right wing started and then
they met on the other between the fence
you know what happened to them and then
they both together were had because they
shared a mission statement yeah so so
the so so the right was labeled
anti-vaxx the left wasn't provex it was
anti-trump they're both anti so whatever
Trump was against they were they were
four so you know yeah uh uh anyways
appreciation for coming out this was a
blast uh I think we've been together for
nearly three hours and it felt like five
minutes
I gotta do this he probably thought you
guys ate me or something
if you enjoyed just give it a thumbs up
subscribe and we'll see you again
tomorrow home team podcast take care
everybody
foreign